This is the 99% of visible breakdown of the Constitution. I'm Roman Mars. And I'm Elizabeth Joe. Today we are discussing Article 2, which establishes the executive branch of the federal government. Our special guest for this episode is Janet Napolitano, who served as Secretary of Homeland Security under President Obama from 2009 to 2013. Prior to that, she was the governor of Arizona, so she has executive experience at the state level as well. and she was the Attorney General of Arizona before that. After leaving the Obama administration, she became the president of the University of California,
这是对宪法可见部分的99%的解读。我是罗曼·马尔斯。我是伊丽莎白·乔。今天我们讨论的是第二条，该条确立了联邦政府的行政部门。我们本期节目的特邀嘉宾是珍妮特·纳波利塔诺，她在2009年至2013年奥巴马总统任内担任国土安全部部长。在此之前，她是亚利桑那州州长，因此她也拥有州级行政经验，在此之前她还担任过亚利桑那州总检察长。离开奥巴马政府后，她成为了加州大学的校长，
the largest public university system in the country. Today, she teaches at the Goldman School of Public Policy at UC Berkeley. Later in the show, Elizabeth explains the Trump administration's attacks on Venezuelan boats through the lens of constitutional law. But first, our Article 2 conversation with Janet Napolitano. Secretary Napolitano, thank you so much. for being on the show. Oh, thank you. So Article 2 establishes the executive branch using probably the vagus terms possible. Section 2 of Article 2 contemplates that there will be a
这是全国最大的公立大学系统。如今，她在加州大学伯克利分校的戈德曼公共政策学院任教。在节目后半段，伊丽莎白将从宪法法的角度解读特朗普政府对委内瑞拉船只的攻击。但首先，是我们与珍妮特·纳波利塔诺关于第二条的对话。纳波利塔诺部长，非常感谢您参加我们的节目。哦，谢谢。那么，第二条确立了行政部门，使用的措辞可能是最含糊不清的。第二条第二款设想将有一个
cabinet, but not much is specified beyond that in terms of a job description. There's no required meetings, for example. So when you were Secretary of Homeland Security, was that job an extension of what the president wants, or is the president expecting you to come up with lots of policy proposals? like, how does it work in practice? Well, I think how it works in practice varies with whomever is the president. I was secretary under President Obama, and it was a combination of things. You're a member of the cabinet, so there's an expectation that you're going to be carrying out the policies that have been enunciated by the White House.
内阁，但在职位描述方面除了这一点之外没有做太多具体规定。例如，没有强制性的会议。所以，当您担任国土安全部长时，那份工作是总统意愿的延伸，还是总统期望您提出大量的政策建议？比如，它在实践中是如何运作的？嗯，我认为它在实践中如何运作取决于谁是总统。我在奥巴马总统任内担任部长，这是多种因素的结合。你是内阁成员，所以人们期望你会执行白宫阐明的政策。
But those policies, particularly in the Homeland Security area, which deals with everything from cybersecurity to disaster response to immigration and all the complications with immigration. Those policies need to generate from somewhere. And so President Obama used his cabinet to help generate policy ideas as well as using the National Security Council and the Domestic Policy Council as well.
但这些政策，特别是在国土安全领域，涉及从网络安全到灾难应对再到移民以及与移民相关的所有复杂情况。这些政策需要从某个地方产生。因此，奥巴马总统利用他的内阁来帮助产生政策想法，同时也利用了国家安全委员会和国内政策委员会。
And so what did that look like on a sort of day-to-day basis? Are you sort of implementing, you know, you have a team that comes up with different kinds of, how are we going to respond to this initiative? Is that how it works? Well, yeah, and that's really important because how you implement or operationalize, to use that word, a policy, particularly when you're dealing with a huge federal department, is a management challenge, among other things.
那么这在日常工作中是什么样子的呢？你们是在执行，你知道的，你们有一个团队来提出各种不同的意见，我们该如何应对这个倡议？是这样运作的吗？嗯，是的，这真的很重要，因为你如何实施或用这个词来运作一项政策，特别是当你面对一个庞大的联邦部门时，管理本身就是一个挑战。
You've got to figure out the FTE, you've got to figure out the resources, you've got to figure out the deployments. You've got to figure out the logistics. You've got to, and then you've got to have some way to actually monitor and see whether what you're doing is achieving the policy result that is intended. And so it's a constant kind of push-pull sort of thing. And it can be easy. It could be tough. I remember when we started DACA, Deferred Action for Childhood Arrivals. That was a brand new policy. It was generated by, actually by me, by the Secretary of Homeland Security, went to the White House, got the White House's approval, got the President's
你必须计算全职员工人数（FTE），你必须计算资源，你必须计算部署。你必须弄清楚物流。你必须，然后你必须有一些方法来实际监控和观察你所做的事情是否达到了预期的政策结果。所以这是一种持续的推拉过程。它可能很容易。也可能很艰难。我记得当我们启动DACA（童年抵美者暂缓遣返计划）时。那是一个全新的政策。它是由我，也就是国土安全部长发起的，提交给白宫，获得了白宫的批准，得到了总统的
blessing. He actually announced it from the Rose Garden. But then he gave us 60 days to actually put this new policy into practice. And we had to first of all, design the forms, set the fee because there was no appropriation for it, educate the people who were going to be reviewing the DACA applications, educate the community at large who were working with young people who were eligible for DACA and do that all in record time. If you think about setting up a federal program in 60 days, that's kind of rocket speed. That's right. But we were able to do it, and we didn't know. We didn't know on the first day whether we'd have five people or 500 or 5,000. And it turned out it was a very popular program. I think at its peak, we had about 850,000 young people enrolled in DACA. But that was an illustration of an idea that originated in a cabinet department that went to the White House, got the president's approval, and then was sent back to the
祝福。他实际上是在玫瑰园宣布这一消息的。但随后他给我们60天的时间来真正将这项新政策付诸实践。我们首先必须设计表格，由于没有为此拨款，所以要设定费用，教育将要审查DACA申请的人员，教育那些与符合DACA条件的小年轻合作的广大社区，并且在创纪录的时间内完成所有这些工作。如果你考虑在60天内建立一个联邦程序，那简直是火箭般的速度。没错。但我们做到了，而且我们并不知道。我们在第一天并不知道我们会拥有5个人、500人还是5,000人。事实证明，这是一个非常受欢迎的项目。我认为在巅峰时期，我们有大约85万名年轻人加入了DACA。但这说明了一个想法：它起源于一个内阁部门，提交给白宫，获得了总统的批准，然后被送回
cabinet department to actually implement. On other examples, the word kind of came from the White House. We want you to do X, and you figure out how to do X. I'm so glad that you mentioned DACA. I'd like to, maybe we could familiarize some of our listeners with what the program is if they're not familiar. Of course, DACA started by you in 2012, and it's a program that allows a group of undocumented young adults who arrived in the United States when they were children to be protected from deportation. They're supposed to register and then apply for renewals every two years, if I remember correctly. Now, part of this is you mentioned the idea of implementation, how to implement the president's will or his or her policies. And of course, that goes back to Article 2.
内阁部门去实际实施。在其他例子中，指令某种程度上来自白宫。我们希望你做X，然后由你来弄清楚如何做X。我很高兴你提到了DACA。我想，也许我们可以让一些听众如果不熟悉的话，了解一下这个项目是什么。当然，DACA由你在2012年发起，它是一项允许一群在儿童时期抵达美国的无证年轻成年人免遭驱逐出境的计划。如果我没记错的话，他们应该登记，然后每两年申请一次续签。现在，其中一部分是你提到的实施理念，如何实施总统的意志或他或她的政策。当然，这可以追溯到第二条。
And Article 2, Section 3, we have the Take Care Clause. And of course, Section 3 states that the president shall take care that the laws be faithfully executed. Now, on the one hand, the clause imposes a kind of obligation or duty on the part of the president. That means the president, and really the executive branch, must execute the laws Congress passes. On the other hand, the take care clause is also a presidential power. It's the executive branch alone that has the authority to make sure federal laws followed. Now, previously, when you've talked about DACA, you've mentioned that when you first created it, you and your team focused a lot on the word shall. I wonder if you could talk a little bit more about that.
在第二条第三款中，我们有“忠实执行条款”。当然，第三款规定总统应确保法律得到忠实执行。一方面，该条款对总统施加了一种义务或职责。这意味着总统，以及真正的行政部门，必须执行国会通过的法律。另一方面，“忠实执行条款”也是一种总统权力。唯有行政部门才有权力确保联邦法律得到遵守。此前，当您谈到DACA时，您曾提到在最初创建它时，您和您的团队非常关注“应当”（shall）这个词。我想知道您是否能多谈谈这一点。
Well, we didn't focus on the text of the Constitution when we were forming DACA. I mean, the lawyers looked at it, the Department of Justice looked at it, and concluded that it was within the executive power of the president. Because in the field of law enforcement, and immigration really is law enforcement, there's enormous discretion that is given to prosecutors and enforcers to set priorities, right? Because you never have the resources to prosecute everyone. So to set priorities and then to implement those priorities that are set. And I think that falls within the take care clause because that is the only common sense way to interpret it.
嗯，我们在制定DACA时并没有关注宪法的文本。我的意思是，律师们看过它，司法部看过它，并得出结论认为这属于总统的行政权力范围内。因为在执法领域——而移民实际上就是执法——检察官和执法人员拥有巨大的自由裁量权来设定优先事项，对吧？因为你永远没有足够的资源去起诉每一个人。因此，要设定优先事项，然后落实这些设定好的优先事项。我认为这属于忠实执行条款的范畴，因为这是解释它的唯一常识性方式。
And you mentioned this idea of this law enforcement description. You know, that's actually part of what's in the memo that you signed when you established DACA, that this, in your view, as an example of prosecutorial discretion. You know, can you explain a little bit more about what you mean by that term or what was meant at the time and how that actually justifies the DACA program itself? Sure. So, prosecutorial discretion, and I'm a former U.S. attorney and a former state attorney general, so it kind of came out of the prosecution ranks. And what it means is that the prosecutor always has a discretion to decide who to charge, what to charge, what to plead, if there's going to be a plea bargain, if there's going to be an offer. And that is inherent in the role of the judgment of the prosecutor. It's supposed to be, until the current administration, guided by very strict standards about the predicates you need to have before. making those decisions and kind of the boundaries in which those decisions can be made.
你提到了这种执法描述的想法。你知道，这实际上是你签署DACA时备忘录中的一部分，在你看来，这是检察裁量权的一个例子。你知道，你能否多解释一下你对这个词的理解，或者当时是什么意思，以及这实际上是如何为DACA项目本身辩护的？当然。所以，检察裁量权——我曾任美国检察官和州总检察长，所以它有点出身于检察官行列。它的意思是检察官始终拥有决定起诉谁、指控什么、认罪什么、是否有认罪协商、是否有发盘的自由裁量权。这是检察官判断职责所固有的。直到本届政府之前，它本应受到非常严格的标准的指导，这些标准关乎你在此之前需要具备的前提条件
But it goes back to, I think, two points. First, that a prosecution is inherently involves some judgment, i.e. discretion. But secondly, no prosecutor's office or law enforcement office has enough people, has enough resources to investigate prosecution. whatever, every conceivable violation of law. And so there are actually guidelines in the U.S. Attorney's Manual to help with the exercise of that discretion. In the immigration context, we translated it in the immigration context, and we were very firmly of the view that the enormous weight of the federal government where immigration is concerned ought to focus on recent border crossers so that they don't get settled into the United States, ought to be focused on those
做出这些决定以及这些决定可以做出的界限。但这可以追溯到，我认为，两点。首先，起诉本身就涉及一些判断，即裁量权。但其次，没有任何检察官办公室或执法办公室拥有足够的人员、足够的资源来调查起诉。无论如何，每一个可以想象的法律违规行为。因此，美国检察官手册中实际上有指南来帮助行使这种裁量权。在移民背景下，我们在移民背景下对其进行了转化，并且我们非常坚信，涉及移民的联邦政府的巨大分量应该集中在最近越境的人身上，这样他们就不会在美国定居，应该集中在那些
in the United States illegally who've committed other crimes and those in the United States for whom we actually had evidence of connection to terrorists or terrorism groups or organized gang activity. But the lowest kind of priority were these young people who were raised in the United States, grew up here, oftentimes had never been to their country of origin once they were here. On the average, were brought to the United States under the age of six years old. And, you know, they'd gone to school. Many of them were trying to go to college. They were trying to, or some had joined the military, et cetera. And we felt that it was both in terms of judgment and in terms of resources, kind of just didn't make sense that they should have to
非法在美国并犯下其他罪行的外国人，以及我们在美国有证据表明他们与恐怖分子、恐怖组织或有组织的团伙活动有联系的人。但优先级最低的是这些在美国长大、在这里成长的年轻人，他们来到这里后往往一次也没有去过他们的原籍国。平均而言，他们在六岁之前被带到美国。而且，你知道，他们上过学。他们中的许多人正试图上大学。他们正试图，或者有些人加入了军队，等等。我们觉得，无论从判断力还是从资源的角度来看，他们不得不
always be looking over their shoulder to see whether there was an ICE agent following them. And also, we thought it made sense that they should have some sort of deferred deportation arrangement, which is what this is, deferred action, that would allow them to get work authorization so that they could actually work while they went to school. They could actually work for a business instead of, you know, trying to get a job and having to be paid under the table and so forth. So it sounds like this is kind of similar to another initiative under President Obama, which was the guidance officially from the Justice Department about not going after every single person who might be violating the federal laws regarding marijuana. So maybe we
时刻提防身后是否有ICE（移民和海关执法局）特工在跟踪他们，这根本说不通。而且，我们认为让他们获得某种暂缓驱逐的安排是合理的，这正是本计划的内容——暂缓遣返（deferred action）——这将允许他们获得工作授权，以便他们实际上可以在上学的同时工作。他们实际上可以为企业工作，而不是，你知道的，试图找一份工作却不得不拿私下现金薪酬等等。所以听起来这有点类似于奥巴马总统时期的另一个倡议，即来自司法部的官方指导意见，关于不要追查每一个可能违反联邦大麻法律的人。所以也许我们
don't have enough resources. So is that fair to say that it's a kind of similar discretion? It's similar. I mean, in fact, the marijuana thing is really kind of funny because I I was the U.S. Attorney for the District of Arizona in Clinton's first term. And, of course, Arizona is a border state. And this was in the early 90s. And we didn't deal with small baggies of marijuana. We were dealing with, like, tons of marijuana being brought over the border. And we would prosecute those big cases.
没有足够的资源。那么，说这是一种类似的裁量权是否公平？是类似的。我的意思是，事实上，大麻那件事真的有点搞笑，因为我在克林顿第一任期内曾担任亚利桑那州地区的美国检察官。而且，当然，亚利桑那州是一个边境州。这是在90年代初。我们不处理一小袋一小袋的大麻。我们处理的是成吨的大麻被带过边境。我们会起诉那些大案子。
No kidding. But the notion that we would then, you know, spend time on personal use cases was kind ludicrous. So DACA was somewhat created in a vacuum of a legislative solution for solving this problem. Can you talk about that role and what it meant to create it and what that vacuum was about? Well, that's true. And the background was there was the young people had organized and they were known colloquially as dreamers. Right. And they now don't use that name. But that was the term that they were known as in Washington, D.C. And the Congress had tried several times to pass a so-called Dream Act to have a statute that would actually do much more than what DACA did.
真的吗。但我们要花时间处理个人使用案件的这种想法简直荒谬。因此，DACA的创建在某种程度上是在解决这个问题的立法方案的真空中进行的。你能谈谈那个角色，以及创建它的意义所在，以及那个真空是什么吗？嗯，确实如此。背景是这些年轻人组织起来了，他们在口头上被称为“追梦者”。对。他们现在不用这个名字了。但那是他们在华盛顿特区为人所知的称呼。国会曾多次试图通过所谓的《梦想法案》，制定一项实际上会比DACA做更多事情的法规。
And the Senate was never able to get to the 60-vote threshold to get it through. So when they failed at the end of, I think it was 2011, to pass. the Dream Act once again. I can remember this clear as day. I called my staff into my office and I said, you know, we've got to do something here. Give me a memo. Give me some options that are possible. And remember, President Obama was very careful on immigration. He didn't want to proceed simply by executive order because he felt this was Congress's responsibility. And I think he's right about that. But in this particular instance, we felt that within the statutes, within the power of the executive, he could adopt a program that, in essence, was a form of
而参议院从未能达到60票的门槛使其通过。因此，当他们在（我想是）2011年底未能通过《梦想法案》时。我清楚地记得这一天。我把我的工作人员叫到办公室，我说：“你知道的，我们必须在这里做点什么。给我写一份备忘录。给我一些可能的选择。”记住，奥巴马总统对移民问题非常谨慎。他不想仅仅通过行政命令继续推进，因为他认为这是国会的责任。我想他在这方面是对的。但在这种特定情况下，我们认为在法规范围内，在行政部门的权力范围内，他可以采纳一项计划，本质上是一种形式的
discretion that was used by the Department of Justice and other sorts of situations and the like. But we had to do some convincing. I mean, the White House was initially a little bit, they really wanted to make sure the eyes were dotted and the T's were crossed. So that brings me back to this idea of discretion again. You know, I think one of the things people are trying to do is understand the current moment and the way that the White House is flexing its authority. So if the president has the broad authority to establish a program like DACA, which is, as you say, an exercise of executive discretion,
司法部和其他类似情况下使用的裁量权。但我们必须做一些说服工作。我的意思是，白宫起初有点，他们真的很想确保各项细节都万无一失。这就让我回到了关于裁量权的这个概念。你知道，我认为人们正在尝试做的事情之一是了解当前的时刻以及白宫伸展其权力的方式。因此，如果总统拥有广泛的权力来建立像DACA这样的计划，正如你所说，这是行政裁量权的行使，
well, isn't that the same broad authority that President Trump in his first term, relied on to justify the travel ban on majority Muslim countries. And couldn't it simply also be the same broad authority to justify some of these really frightening immigration raids that we've seen around the country? Is that all part of the same spectrum of discretion? I think they're different issues. DACA was a, in essence, was a very confined program that fits squarely. I thought, with unprecedented, interestingly enough, the first Trump administration tried to rescind DACA.
难道这不是特朗普总统在其第一任期内用来为针对多数穆斯林国家的旅行禁令辩护的同样的广泛权力吗？难道它不能同样成为为我们在全国各地看到的这些真正可怕的移民突袭行动辩护的广泛权力吗？这难道不是裁量权同一光谱的一部分吗？我认为它们是不同的问题。DACA本质上是一个非常有限的程序，完全契合。我原以为这前所未有，有趣的是，特朗普的第一届政府试图废除DACA。
Right. And remember that? And the University of California, I was then the president. Right, right. We sued them. And it went all the way to the Supreme Court. And the Supreme Court didn't uphold the legality of DACA, but what it said was that the way that the Trump administration had gone about rescinding it, violated the administrative procedure. They had tried to rescind it.
对。还记得吗？而加州大学，我当时是校长。对，对。我们起诉了他们。官司一直打到了最高法院。最高法院并没有维持DACA的合法性，但它表示，特朗普政府废除它的方式违反了行政程序法。他们曾试图废除它。
it incorrectly. But there's still cases out there that brought by Republican attorneys general and others that have challenged the underpinnings, the legal underpinnings of DACA. But when you talk about the travel ban, and when you talk about these raids that are going on, those involve different exercises of immigration authority. The raids, for example, get to what kind of requirements must an ICE agent or a Border Patrol agent have before they can detain somebody? And like I described earlier, we always tried to have a set of priorities for our ICE agents so they didn't just go willy-nilly around streets, pick it up.
但方式不对。不过，仍有一些由共和党总检察长和其他人提起的诉讼，挑战了DACA的基础、法律基础。但当你谈到旅行禁令，当你谈到正在进行的这些突袭时，这些涉及不同维度的移民权力行使。例如，突袭行动触及了ICE特工或边境巡逻特工在拘留某人之前必须具备哪些要求？就像我之前描述的那样，我们总是试图为我们的ICE特工设定一系列优先事项，这样他们就不会在街头随意抓捕。
people because we felt yes agreed people are in the country illegally that that's a violation but like every other thing in the law enforcement realm you don't really have the resources to go after everybody and so you really have to set some priorities with the with the street level raids not only are they I think bad law enforcement policy but they implicate a whole set of rights of the individuals involved that really were not implicated by DACA. You say it's bad law enforcement policy. Could you say a bit more about that? Why you think so?
人们，因为我们觉得，是的，同意人们非法在国家境内，那是违法的，但就像执法领域的其他事情一样，你确实没有资源去追捕每一个人，所以你真的必须设定一些优先事项。对于街头突袭行动，它们不仅我认为是不良的执法政策，而且它们牵涉到相关个人的整套权利，而这些权利在DACA中并未受到牵连。你说这是不良的执法政策。你能多说一点吗？为什么你这么认为？
Oh, for heaven's sake. Yeah. I mean, first of all, you know, it creates enormous tension within the communities that these raids are going out and a whole atmosphere of fear among people who are here legally as well as those here illegally. There have been too many documented instances of abuse by the agents who are out on the street and the fact that they are masked and the fact that they are driving in unmarked vehicles and so forth. Law enforcement is supposed to enforce the rule of law.
哦，天哪。是的。我的意思是，首先，你知道，它在这些遭到突袭的社区内部造成了巨大的紧张局势，并在合法居留的人以及非法居留的人中间营造了一种恐惧的氛围。街头特工滥用职权的记录实例太多了，而且他们戴着面具，开着无标志的车辆等等。执法部门应该执行法治。
Law enforcement agents ought to be clearly identified. They ought to be acting pursuels. suent to clear rules that people understand. And when you think about just kind of law enforcement policy, they're not coordinating with local police. In fact, I think in some of these cities, they've created an enormous problem for local police. So that's a law enforcement problem. The second problem is that they are picking up way too many people. They have no business picking up, i.e. people who are in the country either already legally or who are in the immigration process already. And then third, they have taken away any restriction on going into schools and the churches
执法特工应当被清晰识别。他们应当根据人们能够理解的清晰规则行事。当你只从执法政策的角度来思考时，他们不与当地警察协调。事实上，我认为在其中一些城市，他们给当地警察制造了巨大的问题。所以这是一个执法问题。第二个问题是，他们抓了太多根本不该抓的人，也就是那些本已合法在境内或已经在走移民程序的人。第三，他们取消了对进入学校和教堂的任何限制，
and this business of standing around courthouses where people are actually going for their immigration hearings and then picking them up. Well, talk about a disincentive for people to try to actually legalize their process. and become naturalized citizens, or at least get some legal status within the United States, it seems totally bass-acwards to me. I mean, this is a key part of DACA because you had to convince, you know, these dreamers who were afraid of immigration authorities for most of their lives to trust you enough to go through a federal, like, legalized process to, you know, that they were okay.
以及在人们实际去参加移民听证会法院周围闲晃然后抓走他们的这种做法。好吧，谈谈阻止人们真正试图使他们的程序合法化并成为归化公民，或者至少在美国获得某种合法身份的负面激励机制，在我看来这完全是倒行逆施。我的意思是，这是DACA的关键部分，因为你必须说服，你知道，这些一生中大部分时间都害怕移民当局的追梦者，让他们足够信任你，去经历一个联邦形式的、类似于合法化的程序，让他们知道他们是安全的。
What was that like sort of convincing people and establishing that trust? It was all about trust because many of them were, as you suggest, nervous because, you know, they had to turn over their addresses. They had to turn over the names of their parents, you know, all that kind of basic biographical information. So we had a policy in DACA that the information, the information was collected by a branch of. of the department called USCIS, citizenship and immigration services, that that information would be held only in CIS and not given over to ICE.
说服人们并建立这种信任是什么感觉？这全关乎信任，因为正如你所暗示的那样，他们中的许多人很紧张，因为，你知道，他们必须交出他们的地址。他们必须交出父母的名字，你知道，所有这类基本的传记信息。所以在DACA中我们有一项政策，即这些信息，这些信息由部门的一个分支收集。该部门名为USCIS（公民及移民服务局），该信息将仅保密在CIS中，而不会移交给ICE。
And we adhere to that policy. Of course, in this era, if I were a young person, I think I would be well advised not to apply for DACA because ICE now has been given access to all kinds of information, It's been given access to tax documents by the IRS. It's been trying to get information about people who are enrolled in state benefit programs. So, you know, but it ultimately involved trust.
我们坚持了这一政策。当然，在这个时代，如果我是一个年轻人，我认为我最好不要申请DACA，因为ICE现在已经被赋予了访问各种信息的权限，它已被国税局（IRS）授予访问税务文件的权限。它一直试图获取有关参加州福利计划人员的信息。所以，你知道，但这最终涉及信任。
And when we started DACA, we spent a lot of time with the immigrant community talking about what the program, what it wasn't. It didn't provide for route to citizenship. Only Congress could do that. But it was a temporary fix for these young people so that they could move on with their lives. Well, when you mentioned that it's a temporary fix, you know, what does it mean to you that now, you know, 13 years later, that this really seems to be the only solution and it kind of seems to be fading, actually, for this group of undocumented young people. What does that mean to you now? Well, it gets to the genesis of this conversation, which is what is Congress's responsibility. under Article 1 versus what is the executive's responsibility under Article 2 of the Constitution?
当我们启动DACA时，我们花了很多时间与移民社区讨论这个计划是什么，它不是什么。它不提供通往公民身份的途径。只有国会才能做到这一点。但它是对这些年轻人的一项临时修复，以便他们能够继续他们的生活。好吧，当你提到这是一个临时修复时，你知道，现在13年过去了，这似乎真的是唯一的解决方案，而且对于这群无证年轻人来说，它实际上正在逐渐消退，这对你意味着什么？这对你现在的意义是什么？嗯，这触及了这场对话的起源，那就是国会的责任是什么。
And Congress, unfortunately, our current Congress is just, and this has been going on for too long, but seems incapable of dealing with really big, complicated problems in a way that makes sense. You can see it in things like immigration overall for sure. you can see it just in all the budget craziness and the inability to actually engage in a regularized budget and appropriations process that makes sense. Even under Obama, we were dealing with repeated either threats of shutdowns or shutdowns. Well, try running a department with a quarter of a million employees and a half a million contractors when you're constantly having to send out warnings. you know, oh, you're going to continue to work, but you're not going to get paid while you're working, or you have to stay home. And by the way, you can't access your computer or your phone
根据第一条，而行政部门根据宪法第二条的责任是什么？不幸的是，国会，我们当前的国会简直——这种情况已经持续太久了——似乎无力以一种合理的方式处理真正庞大、复杂的问题。你可以从整体移民等事情中看出这一点，你可以从所有的预算疯狂以及无 A 状态中看出这一点，无力真正参与合理的常规化预算和拨款程序。甚至在奥巴马时期，我们也一直在处理反复出现的政府关闭威胁或政府关闭。好吧，当你不得不不断发出警告时，去管理一个拥有25万名员工和50万名承包商的部门试试看。
or anything else while you're staying home. And, you know, people always say you ought to run government like a business. No business would operate like this. And that ultimately is a failure of the Congress, right? They just can't get their act together. So I think of DACA is this, like, amazing success and a great policy that was forged. out of a failure of the Congress. And so is that always a part of it for you? Like, do you think of it always as being this thing that was done because some part of the system was failing? No.
你知道，“哦，你将继续工作，但在工作时你不会拿到工资，或者你必须呆在家里。”顺便说一句，呆在家里时你无法访问你的电脑或手机或任何其他东西。而且，你知道，人们总是说你应该像经营企业一样管理政府。没有任何企业会这样运作。这归根结底是国会的失败，对吧？他们就是无法把事情理顺。所以我认为DACA是一项了不起的成功，也是一项从国会的失败中锻造出来的伟大政策。所以这总是其中的一部分吗？比如，你是否一直认为这是一件因为系统某一部分失灵而不得不做的事情？不。
I think there are ideas and policies to implement that are more on the executive level, their management level, et cetera, that don't require necessarily an action by Congress. But here's where it gets interesting from a legal point of view, because the Supreme Court is developing these doctrines, you know, the major questions doctrine, the non-delegation doctrine, et cetera, that I think one of their failures is they do not take into account the institutional capabilities of the Congress. You know, they presume that Congress always, what it wants to, can speak clearly and precisely, not giving any kind of give in the system for the congressional process itself, how messy it is, in a way by design, but how messy it is, and how they can actually, by creating these doctrines, presume a capacity that, particularly in the present day, simply doesn't exist. exist. Yeah. You do feel that unrealistic, like they're sort of saving this sort of idealized
我认为有些想法和要实施的政策更多是在行政层面、管理层面等，不一定需要国会的行动。但从法律角度来看，有趣的地方在于，因为最高法院正在制定这些理论（你知道，重大问题原则、不当授权原则等），我认为他们的失败之一是他们没有考虑到国会的体制能力。你知道，他们假定国会总是，在它想要的时候，能够清晰准确地发言，不为国会程序本身提供任何回旋余地，无论它多么混乱，在某种设计上它是混乱的，以及他们如何实际上通过创建这些理论，假定了一种在当今时代根本不存在的能力。存在。是的。你确实觉得不切实际，就像他们是在拯救议员本该做的事情的那种理想化形式。而这，是的，完全是不切实际的。它今天根本不是那样运作的。对。但这很重要，因为国会必须做好自己的工作，以避免行政部门超越我认为在第二条下原本的意图。是的。那么，你是否认为特朗普今天对大量行政命令的使用，是你所看到的超越总统权力边界的一部分？因为行政命令，当然在特朗普之前就已经存在很长时间了。它们存在过，但没有达到这种程度。我们在行政命令的频谱上已经走得太远了。而且，你知道，通过行政命令进行统治，这里的问题在于，你可以做任何事，你知道，你可以，你可以，你可以通过行政命令进行统治，下一个行政长官来把它撤回。因此，除了滥用权力和过度使用权力之外，它还在政府内部造成了不稳定。我认为我在特朗普2.0和现任政府中一直感到困扰的事情之一
form of what the legislators are supposed to do. And it just, yeah, it is completely unrealistic. It doesn't function today like that at all. Right. But it's important because Congress has to do its job to avoid the executive exceeding what was intended, I believe, under Article 2. Yeah. And so do you see that Trump's use today of just a whole slew of executive orders, is that part of what you see as the exceeding the boundaries of what the president can do? Because executive orders, of course, have existed for a long time prior to Trump. They've existed, but not to this degree. We are so far along executive order spectrum. And, you know, governing by executive order, here's the problem with it, which is you can do any, you know, you can, you can, you know, you can, governed by executive order, the next executive comes by and retracts it. So it creates instability in the government in addition to overuse of an abuse of power. And I think one of the things that I've been troubled by in Trump 2.0 in the current administration
这才是立法者应该做的事情的形式。这完全不切实际。它现在根本不是那样运作的。没错。但这一点很重要，因为国会必须做好自己的工作，以避免行政权超越我所认为的第二条所赋予的意图。是的。那么，你认为特朗普今天大量使用行政命令的做法，是否属于你所看到的超越总统权限边界的行为？因为行政命令在特朗普之前当然就已经存在很久了。它们确实存在，但没有达到这种程度。我们在行政命令的道路上走得太远了。而且，你知道，通过行政命令来治理，这里面的问题在于，你可以做任何……你可以通过行政命令来治理，但下一个上台的行政长官会将其撤销。因此，除了权力过度使用和滥用之外，它还给政府造成了不稳定。我认为，在特朗普2.0和当前的行政当局中，有一件事一直让我感到困扰
is the Supreme Court's willingness under the so-called shadow docket to let so many of these executive orders stand, and the harm is being incurred while the underlying merits case is still being litigated. I think if we want to talk about an abuse of power, that's the Supreme Court's abuse of power and the executive's abuse of power. And so I think we're really in a constitutional quandary right now. Do you have a remedy for how we're supposed to get out of it? Well, I think the Supreme Court needs to do its job. It doesn't need to take all these cases. It can let the lower court injunctions stand while the cases are being litigated. I think they've been too eager to reach out and take cases that are not fully brief, that are not fully considered, and kind of bless
是最高法院愿意根据所谓的“影子 docket（紧急 docket）”让如此多的行政命令继续有效，而在底层实体案件仍在诉讼中时，损害就已经造成了。我认为如果我们想谈论滥用权力，那就是最高法院的滥用权力以及行政部门的滥用权力。所以我认为我们现在确实陷入了宪法困境。你有什么办法能让我们摆脱困境吗？嗯，我认为最高法院需要做好它的本职工作。它不需要受理所有这些案件。在案件还在诉讼过程中时，它可以让下级法院的禁令保持有效。我认为他们太急于插手并受理那些没有充分简短陈述、没有充分审议的案件，并以一行命令的形式对它们进行“祝福”，而不是说，你知道吗，我们要让地方法院关于解雇所有这些联邦官员、终止所有这些程序或罢免独立机构中所有这些委员的禁令保持有效，当这些案件经过正常程序后，我们会予以受理。因为按照目前的运作方式，损害已经造成了。而且这种损害是在这种，你知道，类似于禁令的层面造成的，而不是像关税案那样。现在，关税案很有意思，因为它已经经过了充分的简报、充分的辩论。这是一个引人入胜、非常重要的案件。
them in one-line orders, as opposed to saying, you know what, we're going to let the district court's injunction against firing all these federal employees or terminating all these programs or getting rid of all of these commissioners on independent agencies, we're going to let those stand and we will take those cases when they've gone through the normal process. Because the way it's been working, the harm is already being incurred. And it's being incurred at this, you know, kind of injunctive level as opposed to like the tariff case. Now, the tariff case is interesting because it's been fully briefed, fully argued. It's a fascinating, very important case.
但想想如果最高法院插手并在影子 docket上做出决定。你知道，我确信他们中的一些人很想这样做。这就是我所说的意思，他们运作的方式似乎没有遵循正常的最高法院惯例。最高法院是美国法治的最终仲裁者。当他们不给我们他们的法律推理，当他们仓促下达一行命令时，这就好比，好吧，我也可以下达一行命令。我的意思是，但我希望看到最高法院说出依据，给我们法律、法律分析以及他们决定背后的推理。
But think if the Supreme Court had reached out and decided that on the shadow docket. You know, and I'm sure some of them were tempted to. So that's what I mean by saying that the way they've been operating seems to me to not follow normal Supreme Court practice. And the Supreme Court is the ultimate arbiter of the rule of law in the United States. And when they don't give us their legal reasoning, when they rush to one-line orders, it's like, well, I could do a one-line order. I mean, but I want to see what the Supreme Court says there is to give us the law, the legal analysis, the reasoning behind their decisions.
我觉得这会使他们看起来不那么像又一个政治分支（像国会或行政部门），而更像是他们本应成为的样子。我知道我们现在已经偏离到第三条了，但管他呢。它们都是相互关联的。是的。所以如果你暗示，而且我想我们在这里都同意，国会没有真正站出来，最高法院也没有，现在你处于一个独特的地位，既担任过联邦政府的最高层，又担任过一个非常重要州的州长。在你看来，各州现在的作用是什么，或许可以制衡总统正在做的事情？哦，我认为这也是一个引人入胜的问题。你确实可以在对国民警卫队的使用中看到这一点。所以我是前州长。你知道，
And I think it would make them look much less like just another political branch, like the Congress or the executive, and more like what they are supposed to be. I know we've straight into Article 3 now, but what the heck. They all talk to each other. Yeah. So if you're suggesting, and I think we all agree here, that Congress is not really stepping up and the Supreme Court isn't either, now you're in the unique position of having been the highest levels of the federal government and having been governor of a government. a very important state. What do you see as the role of the states now and maybe checking what the president is doing? Oh, I think this is also a fascinating issue. And you see it really come to life in this use of the National Guard. So I'm a former governor. You know,
你的国民警卫队的指挥官通常坐在州长的内阁里。出于各种原因，你在州内使用他们，紧急服务。当我担任州长时，我们确实将国民警卫队部署到边境，不是为了进行实际抓捕或什么的，而是为了处理类似于后台办公室的工作，因为当时有大量的人越过亚利桑那州边境，以便解放那些实际指派去警察边境的联邦特工。所以，有，有，州长拥有非常重要的工具。他们是州的所谓“民兵”。而且总统在遭到州长反对的情况下将警卫队联邦化，
the commander of your National Guard typically sits in a governor's cabinet. You use them for all kinds of reasons in the state, emergency services. We actually deployed the guard to the border when I was governor, not to do actual apprehensions or anything, but to handle kind of back office work because there was just a huge number of people coming across the Arizona border then to free up the federal agents who are actually assigned to police the border. So there are, there are, of, very important tool that a governor has. They're the state, quote, militia. And the notion that the president would federalize the guard over the governor's objection,
在遭到市长反对的情况下，只是把他们派去驻扎很长时间。我的意思是，你必须认识到警卫队中的男男女女，他们在外面有真正的职业。他们是平民。对。我的意思是，他们每个月奉献几个周末给警卫队，并在夏天进行两周的训练，诸如此类。但他实际上在某些城市几乎像对待占领军一样使用他们，而全然不顾州长的反对。
over the mayor's objection, and just send them in for long periods of time. I mean, you have to recognize the men and women in the guard, they have real jobs on the outside. They're civilians. Right. I mean, they give a couple weekends. a month to the guard and two weeks of training in the summer whatsoever. But he's actually almost using them in some cities like an occupation force over the objection of governors.
我认为这里的法规需要澄清，即总统何时、如何以及在何等情况下可以将国民警卫队联邦化。稍后回来，我们将继续与纳波利塔诺部长的对话。因此，国土安全部成立于2002年，相比之下，国务院成立于1789年左右。所以，而且你是领导这个庞大机构的第三个人，管理着从边境控制到飓风救援的一切，你知道。我读了你在特朗普第一任期内出版的书。而且，你知道，有很多内容，比如你在使用这台机器的同时也在建造这台机器，甚至在那个时候也是如此。
And I think that the statute needs clarification here as to when and how and under what circumstances the president can federalize the guard. more of our conversation with Secretary Napolitana when we come back so the Department of Home and Security was created in 2002 compared to the State Department was created in like 1789 so and and you were the third person to lead this massive agency and managed everything from border control to hurricane relief you know And I read your book that you published during the first Trump term. And, you know, there's a lot of, like, you kind of building the machine as you're using the machine, even at that point.
你是如何弄清楚你能做什么、你的职责范围是什么、你不能做什么的？我的意思是，宪法没有提供太多建议，这与列出国会能做和不能做的事情清单的第一条不同。所以你如何开始弄清楚这个部门是，你知道，有能力实现什么的？这是一个好问题。所以，你知道，DHS是在9·11袭击之后成立的。其起源在于这样一种假设：如果各个部门在一个保护伞下，它们会更好地相互沟通，它们的行动会得到更好的协调，也许另一次，它可以帮助防止另一次9·11。我的意思是，这确实是DHS成立的初衷。然后他们决定，他们把所有东西都扔进了这个部门。
How do you figure out what you can do, what your remit is, what you can't do? I mean, the Constitution doesn't provide a lot of advice here, unlike Article 1, which has a list of things Congress can and can't do. So how do you begin to sort of figure out what the department is, you know, is capable of achieving? That's a good question. So, you know, DHS was created in the wake of the attack of 9-11. And the genesis of it was this kind of presumption that if various departments were under one umbrella, they would communicate with each other better, their actions would be better coordinated, and maybe another, it could help prevent another 9-11. I mean, that's really what DHS was deciding to. And so then they decided, they just threw everything in the department.
然后我，正如你所说，是第三任部长，有23个独立的机构被归入国土安全部，还创建了一些新的机构，比如我们将机场安检联邦化，归入TSA（运输安全管理局）。所以，你知道，我们有，有23个机构，但部门内部有7个主要的运营机构。所以我把大部分时间花在那7个机构上。有公民及移民服务局（USCIS）、有ICE（移民和海关执法局）、有海关与边境保护局（CBP）、有FEMA（联邦紧急事务管理局）、有TSA，还有，天哪。他们会杀了我。
And so then I was, as you say, the third secretary, and there were 23 separate agencies that were thrown under the Department of Homeland Security and some new ones created, like we federalized airport security under the TSA. And so, you know, we had, there are 23 agencies, but there are seven major operational agencies within the department. And so I spent most of my time with those seven. There's Citizenship and Immigration Services, there's ICE, there's Customs and Border Protection, there's FEMA, there's TSA, and, oh, my gosh. They're going to kill me.
无论如何，还有，我们把大部分时间花在，哦，特勤局（Secret Service）和海岸警卫队（Coast Guard）。抱歉。抱歉。我们花时间，我把大部分时间花在了这些机构的负责人身上。但是，你知道，有情报与分析部门。有一个公民自由办公室。有一个总统任命的隐私办公室。所以，我的意思是，它真的很广泛，相当迷人且重要。
But anyway, and we spent most of my, oh, Secret Service and Coast Guard. Sorry. Sorry. And we spent, I spent most of my time with the heads of those agencies. But, you know, there was intelligence and analysis. There was an office of civil liberties. There was a presidentially appointed privacy office. So, I mean, it was really broad-ranging and quite fascinating and important.
而我所做的是，你知道，你进入这个部门，你是个新手。我是第一位担任部长的民主党人。我是一名州长。所以我非常了解FEMA。我是一名边境州州长。我非常了解移民方面的情况。但是，你知道，我对机场安检一无所知。我不知道，我不知道，你知道，海岸。
And what I did was, you know, you go into this department, you're a newbie. I was the first Democrat to be the secretary. I'm a governor. so I know FEMA very well. I'm a border state governor. I know the immigration side very well. But, you know, I didn't know anything about airport security. I didn't, I didn't, you know, coast.
我来自亚利桑那州。我们没有海岸警卫队。所以，你知道，有很多东西必须去学习，而且必须迅速学习，因为你接管了一个新政府，你必须在头两周内查看预算。所以就是这样。然后，你知道，这就像大型机构面临的任何重大挑战一样。
I'm from Arizona. We didn't have a coast guard. So, you know, so there was a lot of learning that had to be done and done quickly because you take over the new administration, and you've got to look at the budget, like, within the first two weeks. So there was that. And then, you know, it's like any major challenge of a large institution.
你必须明确设定，这些是我想要关注的事情。我有一份半打事情的清单，这些将是我们的重点。我们只是不断地，你知道，即使在日常危机管理等方面（DHS中有很多这样的事情），我们始终专注于，例如，网络安全。你知道，没有人真正谈论网络。在2000年代初，网络安全还没有太多人关注，但我们可以看到它是一个不断增长的威胁载体。因此，我们真正开始着手构建后来成为CISA（网络安全与基础设施安全局）的机构。我们审视了TSA，并开始思考如何变得更具风险意识。
You have to set clear, these are the things I want to focus on. And I had a list of a half a dozen things that were going to be our focus. And we just kept, you know, even in the day-to-day crisis management and so forth, of which there's a lot in DHS, we were always focused on, for example, cybersecurity. You know, nobody was really talking about cyber security. security too much in the early 2000s, but we could see it as a growing threat vector. And so we really embarked on the process of building what became SISA, the Cyber Infrastructure Security Administration. We looked at TSA and we began thinking about how to be more risk
你必须明确设定，这些是我想要关注的事情。我有一份包含半打左右将成为我们工作重点的事情的清单。我们一直在坚持，你知道，即使在国土安全部那种充斥着大量日常危机管理等事务的环境下，我们始终专注于，例如，网络安全。你知道，在2000年代初，并没有多少人在过多地谈论网络安全，但我们能看出它是一个不断增长的威胁载体。因此，我们确实着手构建了后来成为网络安全与基础设施安全局（CISA）的机构。我们审视了运输安全管理局（TSA），并开始思考如何能够更好地应对风险
conscious and how we screen passengers. Did all passengers, we did all passengers, have to undergo the same screening at the airports. And we developed TSA pre-check. Thank you for that. Thank you. I salute you. I've often said that on my gravestone, it's going to be Janet Napolitano developed DACA and pre-check, you know. But that was based on a real policy analysis about, you know, what was the threat information we were getting about airline, air travel.
有意识的，以及我们如何对乘客进行安检。所有的乘客，我们所有的乘客，都必须在机场接受相同的安检吗？于是我们开发了 TSA 预检。谢谢你。谢谢。我向你致敬。我经常说，在我墓碑上会写着：珍妮特·纳波利塔诺开发了 DACA 和预检，你知道的。但那其实是基于一项真正的政策分析，关于我们当时获得的关于航空和乘机安全的情报是什么。
what made sense, what was the technology capability, and so forth. So we're always emphasizing those kind of key priorities. And a new administration will have different priorities. I mean, that's part of the nice thing about changing administrations is you get fresh blood. Right. But one of the not nice things about it is that, and I felt this when you were writing about this during the first Trump term, is the department was being run and used in ways that you didn't agree. with and I can only imagine that feeling is more acute today. I mean, do you think what is happening
什么行得通，技术能力如何，诸如此类。所以我们总是强调那些关键的优先事项。而一个新的政府会有不同的优先事项。我的意思是，更迭政府的好处之一就是你能注入新鲜血液。没错。但其中一个不太好的地方在于——我在你报道第一任特朗普政府时就深有体会——这个部门被管理和使用的方式是你所不同意的，我只能想象这种感觉在今天更加强烈。我是说，你认为现在发生的事情
now calls for different structural changes in DHS or is that possible? Or how do you see what was created and how it's being used today and what to do about it if there is anything? Personally, I don't think it's a matter of moving different elements of the department to different agencies and splitting it up and all that. I don't think that's worth the time effort. or trouble to do. It requires a different White House and a different secretary, just plain point of act. There's nothing about the department that is inherently wrong, but it is a very challenging department with a huge remit. And it has to be carefully administered. It is not solely the Department of Immigration Enforcement,
是否需要对国土安全部进行不同的结构性改革，这可能吗？或者你如何看待曾经建立的机构以及它今天的运作方式，如果有什么需要做的，该怎么做？就我个人而言，我不认为这是把部门的不同要素转移到不同机构并将其拆分之类的问题。我认为这不值得花时间、精力或麻烦去去做。说白了，这需要一个不同的白宫和一位不同的部长。这个部门本身并没有什么根本上的不对，但它是一个极具挑战性、职责极其庞大的部门。
although that's what you would think if you saw the White House and how the current secretary manages it. You know, FEMA, which has come under attack in the current administration for, you know, when I took over, FEMA was still suffering from post-Katrina issues because it had failed. It clearly failed. in Katrina. So here's what we did. We went out and recruited a head of FEMA who was the head of
必须对其实施审慎的管理。它不仅仅是移民执法部，尽管如果你看了白宫以及现任部长是如何管理它的，你可能会这么认为。你知道的，联邦紧急事务管理局（FEMA）在现任政府中受到了攻击，因为，你知道的，当我接手时，FEMA 仍然在承受着卡特里娜飓风之后的种种问题，因为它失败了。它在卡特里娜事件中显然失败了。所以我们是这样做的：我们出去招募了一位 FEMA 负责人，他曾是
emergency services for the state of Florida. So he knew hurricanes like the back of his hand. And he had just a solid, not only experiential grounding in emergency management and recovery, but also really strong ideas about how FEMA ought to operate and its role vis-a-vis cities and states, in terms of emergency preparation and response. And we did a lot on FEMA, in fact, toward the end of the first term, President Obama's first term, we had Hurricane Sandy that came up into New York Harbor. And that response was night and day from what had happened in Katrina. And that was because of, you know, years of work to improve FEMA.
佛罗里达州的应急服务负责人。所以他对飓风了如指掌。他不仅在应急管理和恢复方面拥有扎实的实干经验，而且对于 FEMA 应当如何运作，以及它在应急准备和响应方面与城市和州的关系，有着非常深刻的见解。我们在 FEMA 做了很多工作，事实上，在第一任期结束时——奥巴马的第一任期，桑迪飓风袭击了纽约港。那次的应对与卡特里娜飓风时有着天壤之别。这是因为多年的改进 FEMA 的工作。
But FEMA plays a critical role, and you don't know you need FEMA until you need FEMA, right? And the notion that you can just devolve all those resources, all that experience and talent to go state by state by state doesn't make any sense. But FEMA is part of the Department of Homeland Security. Why? Because if you want people to feel safe and secure, they need to have some confidence that when the hurricane hits, the earthquake happens, the forest fire comes swooping down, that there will be capacity to help them. So your example of, you know, how you decided to pick a head of FEMA, so brings to mind the current moment in which there's been a kind of attack on expertise. I mean, you clearly wanted an expert to head FEMA. And we see a lot of this sort of, you know, don't trust the experts, whether we were talking about science and, you know, even crisis management.
但 FEMA 发挥着至关重要的作用，在你需要它之前，你意识不到你需要 FEMA，对吧？那种认为你可以把所有这些资源、所有这些经验和人才下放到一个个州去的想法根本说不通。但 FEMA 是国土安全部的一部分。为什么？因为如果你想让人们感到安全和安心，他们就需要有一定的信心：当飓风袭来、地震发生、森林大火席卷而来时，会有能力去帮助他们。所以你举的关于如何决定挑选 FEMA 负责人的例子，让我想起了当下这个对专业知识进行攻击的时期。我的意思是，你显然希望由专家来领导 FEMA。我们看到了很多这种“不要相信专家”的现象，无论我们谈论的是科学，甚至是危机管理。
What's your view on how that's affecting the federal government at large? I think they're hollowing out the federal government. And, you know, here's the thing. It's easy to destroy. It is hard to build. And when you look at the leadership at the Department of Defense, Department of War, which is the largest federal department. When you look at DHS, when you look at what they've done at the Department of Health
你对这种现象如何影响整个联邦政府有何看法？我认为他们在掏空联邦政府。而且，问题在于：破坏很容易，建设却很难。当你看看国防部、战争部的领导层——这是最大的联邦部门；当你看看国土安全部，当你看看他们在卫生与公众服务部所做的一切，
and Human Services, you know, you have to ask yourself, is our country safer? Are people healthier? Are we better? Because we don't have people who are qualified and confident enough in themselves to rely on experts. running the government? And I would have to say no. Absolutely we're not. And when you look at foreign policy, now foreign policy is kind of a key power of the executive. Article 2 really gives the president that. But in prior administrations, you had a whole process. You had the National Security Council, for example, that considered options. And they went to the deputies
你知道的，你不得不问自己：我们的国家更安全了吗？人们更健康了吗？我们变得更好了吗？因为我们没有那些具备资格、对自己有足够信心去依赖专家的人来管理政府？我不得不说：没有。我们绝对没有。当你看看外交政策时，外交政策可以说是行政部门的一项关键权力。宪法第二条确实赋予了总统这项权力。但在以往的政府中，你有一整套流程。例如，你有国家安全委员会来审议各种方案。他们会将其提交给副手
and the Principals Committee, the National Security Advisor. So when the president made decisions, he was well advised about options that he had and also possible pros and cons of those options, which ever way he went. And the professionals in that world are professionals. They'll do what the elected official ultimately tells them to do. But in the current administration, I can't identify what the national security process. is, you know, beyond, you know, whom the president talked to last. And so, and that should be of concern to everyone because that is a core presidential power,
和主要官员委员会以及国家安全顾问。因此，当总统做出决定时，他能够就自己拥有的选项以及无论选择哪条路可能带来的利弊获得充分的咨询。那个世界里的专业人士都是专业人士。他们会做选举产生的官员最终告诉他们要做的事。但在现任政府中，我甚至无法识别国家安全决策流程是什么样的，
but it needs to be well exercised. I mean, what you're pointing to is a big part of the sort of ongoing project that Elizabeth and I have been, when we've been discussing the Constitution in reference to Trump, is that there is a bunch of stuff that isn't in black and white in the Constitution. it is all about norms and procedures and stuff that is not written down. And a lot of it depends on the personality of the people's involved and the sort of ethics and ideologies of the people's involved in ways that I don't know if the average American knew until this moment.
除了总统最近跟谁谈过之外。所以，这应该引起所有人的关注，因为这是核心的总统权力，但它需要被很好地行使。我的意思是，你所指出的，是伊丽莎白和我一直在进行的关于宪法和特朗普的持续探讨中的很大一部分，那就是宪法中其实有很多东西并不是黑白分明的，它们全都是关于惯例、程序以及那些没有被写下来的东西。而这很大程度上取决于相关人员的个性以及相关人员的道德和意识形态，这种程度在此之前我不知道普通美国人是否真的了解。
And so, you know, what does this make you think of vis-a-vis the Constitution in terms of like the actual operation of the government? Well, I think you're exactly right. the president has, he's got his own set of norms. I mean, he's an unusual sui generis character in American politics in a way. I hope he's sui generis. But norms have a function.
所以，你知道的，就政府的实际运作而言，这让你对宪法有什么样的思考？嗯，我认为你说得完全正确。总统有他自己的一套惯例。我的意思是，他在美国政治中是一个不同寻常的、独一无二的人物。我希望他是独一无二的。但惯例是有功能的。
And when I think reflexively of my time in federal service, so as a U.S. attorney, under Clinton, I was a secretary under Obama. I was on President Biden's Intelligence Advisory Board. What I am critical myself of is we didn't think enough about how to make government better, how to evolve it, move it forward. So it was the most efficient and fair government that the people could expect. In other words, we relied too much on norms instead of saying, well, does this one still make sense?
当我不假思索地回想我在联邦服务的时光时——作为克林顿手下的美国联邦检察官，作为奥巴马手下的内阁部长，我曾担任拜登总统的情报顾问委员会成员——我对自己的批判是：我们没有足够地思考如何让政府变得更好，如何让它演进、向前发展。从而使之成为人民所能期待的最有效、最公平的政府。换句话说，我们过于依赖惯例，而不是去思考：“这个惯例现在还说得通吗？
Or maybe we ought to do it differently. Maybe we ought to do this or that. And that kind of just our assumptions that things were working fine, I think, caught up with us. And I think, you know, when you look at the election of, particularly the election of 2024, I think the voters were saying, you know what, we're not happy. We want something different. Well, they got something different. I don't think they got what they thought they were going to get, but they got something different.
或者也许我们应该换一种方式来做？也许我们应该做这个或那个？”这种仅仅假设一切运转良好的心态，我认为最终让我们自食其果。而且我认为，当你看看选举，特别是2024年的选举时，我认为选民们是在说：“你知道吗？我们很不高兴。我们需要改变。”好吧，他们得到了改变。我不认为他们得到了他们以为会得到的东西，但他们的确得到了改变。
Yeah. Interesting. Yeah. But, you know, for us to say, you know, when the Democrats ultimately take the White House back or what have you and we'll restore the government, I think that's the wrong way to think about it. I think what we ought to be thinking about is how do we make government better in a better way? How do we actually support the experts that we need? How do we actually recruit and retain the best talent to be in these positions? How do we actually have processes that move decision making with more alacrity than
是的。有趣。是的。但是，如果我们认为——当民主党最终夺回白宫或发生类似情况时，我们将恢复政府——我认为这种想法是错误的。我认为我们应该思考的是：我们如何以更好的方式让政府变得更好？我们如何真正支持我们所需的专家？我们如何真正招募并留住最优秀的人才来担任这些职位？我们如何真正建立能够以比过去更高的效率推进决策的流程？
than in the past. How do we better use technology to help with people who need access to services, who need access to information? I think we ought to be thinking forward, not only in terms of restoration. In a practical way, though,
如何更好地利用技术来帮助那些需要获取服务、需要获取信息的人？我认为我们应该向前看，而不仅仅是想着恢复。不过，从实际的角度来看，
are you concerned that, you know, in a future administration, beyond Trump, it's going to be hard to say, hey, come and be a scientist at the EPA and work for the next 20 years with us or, you know, come and be someone who works for the FDA and work on, you know, drug science, you know, is our people going to be willing to, maybe it's not a restoration, but to try this new project for the long haul. What do you think about that?
你是否担心在未来的政府中，除了特朗普之外，人们会很难说：“嘿，来环保局当科学家吧，跟我们一起工作20年”，或者“嘿，来食药监局工作，从事药物科学研究”？人们是否还愿意，也许这不叫恢复，而是长期参与这个新项目？你对此怎么看？
I think that's a really hard question, and we won't know until that time comes. But, you know, the people, so many of the people I've met in government, career civil servants, they have an ethos. They want to spend their lives helping things be better for other people, to put it basically. And you can't do that in the private sector. I mean, it's a different ethos than the private sector. And, you know, the notion of just willy-nilly firing people and moving things, don't get me started about Doge. But, you know, the fact of the matter is we live in a very large,
我觉得这是一个非常难的问题，在那个时刻到来之前我们不会知道答案。但是，你知道的，我在政府中遇到过的许多人，那些职业公务员，他们有一种精神内核。简单来说，他们希望用毕生精力让其他人的生活变得更好。你无法在私营部门做到这一点。我的意思是，这与私营部门有着不同的精神内核。而且，那种随心所欲地解雇员工、搬迁机构的想法——别让我开始吐槽政府效率部（Doge）了。但事实是，我们生活在一个非常庞大、
complex, diverse, diverse. It's urban, it's rural, it's east, it's west, it's many types of ethnicities and backgrounds and histories. It's a, it's a complicated place. But the federal government should serve as, and serve as kind of the bones, right? The skeleton on which all of these other things can happen. And where people can feel with some sense of confidence that basic problems, their basic problems, are being dealt with, and that the future is moving forward. And when you denude the federal government, when you remove expertise, when you make the federal government not an attractive place for really good people to work, that in the end hurts all of us.
复杂、多元的地方。这里有城市，有乡村；有东部，也有西部；有各种种族、背景和历史。这是一个复杂的地方。但联邦政府应当充当、并且也应当充当某种基石，对吧？它是所有这些其他事情得以发生的骨架。在这里，人们可以带着某种确信感，感到基本问题——他们面临的基本问题——正在得到处理，未来正在向前发展。当你削弱联邦政府，当你剥夺专业知识，当你让联邦政府不再成为吸引优秀人才工作的地方时，到头来伤害的是我们所有人。
Well, Secretary DePolitano, thank you so much for talking with us. about Article 2 and about your experience, I just had a great time with our conversation. This was wonderful. Thank you for your time. Thank you for DACA. Preechuk. Thank you all. Enjoyed it. Coming up, what Trump can teach us about con law. The Warpower Edition. So we are now into the What Trump Can Teach us about con law, unfortunately. the show. It is November 20th, 1115 a.m. as we are recording this, what are we going to be talking about today? Okay, Roman, here's a question for you. Was the Civil War a war?
好的，纳波利塔诺部长，非常感谢您与我们谈论宪法第二条以及您的经验，我非常享受与您的这次对话。这太棒了。谢谢您的时间。谢谢您带来的 DACA 和预检项目。谢谢大家。很愉快。接下来，特朗普能给我们带来哪些关于宪法的内容？战争权力版。所以我们现在进入了“特朗普能给我们带来哪些关于宪法的内容”，不幸的是，这档节目。现在是录音时的11月20日上午11点15分，我们今天要聊些什么呢？好的，罗曼，我来问你一个问题：南北战争是一场战争吗？
Oh, God. Huh. Uh, uh, whoa. Let's say, declared. I'm trying to think of like what I know from Article 1 at this point. Oh, you could just have it off the cuff. Yeah, I mean, I'm going to say yes. I, yes, the Civil War was a war. Let's go with that. Yeah, I think that's right. And it might seem obvious to us now that it was a war. But in 1863, it was an open question and a dangerous question for President Lincoln. And that was because of the Amy Warwick, the Hiawatha, the Briante, and the Crenshaw, all four ships that were captured by the U.S. Navy. Now, after Confederate troops fired on the U.S. Army garrison at Fort Sumter in April of 1861, and that's the start of the Civil War, President Lincoln responded by issuing a series of executive proclamations. He called up
哦，天哪。哈。呃，呃，哇。我们姑且认为，它是宣战了。我试着想想我这时候从宪法第一条里学到了什么。哦，你可以随性地回答。好吧，我的回答是“是”。是的，南北战争是一场战争。我们就这么定吧。是的，我想这没错。现在对我们来说，它是一场战争似乎是显而易见的。但在1863年，这是一个悬而未决的问题，对林肯总统来说也是一个危险的问题。这是因为“艾米·沃里克号”、“海华沙号”、“布里安特号”和“克伦肖号”这四艘被美国海军捕获的船只。在南方邦联军队于1861年4月向萨姆特堡的美国陆军 garrison 开火（这标志着南北战争的开始）之后，林肯总统通过发布一系列行政公告做出了回应。他征召了
75,000 volunteer soldiers to form what would become the Union Army. And Lincoln also issued a naval blockade of the South. Now, this was meant to cut off supplies to the Confederacy and to prevent it from selling its goods overseas to raise funds for the Confederate Army. All of this was premised on Lincoln's Warpower as president. Now, why a naval blockade? A blockade meant that the U.S. Navy could seize private ships that were violating the blockade, and in fact, such a ship and its cargo could be claimed as a prize of war. By the 18th century, there existed a complex body of law called
7万5千名志愿兵来组建后来成为联邦军队的队伍。林肯还对南方实施了海上封锁。此举旨在切断对邦联的物资供应，并阻止其向海外出售商品来为邦联军队筹集资金。这一切都建立在林肯作为总统的战争权力之上。为什么要实施海上封锁？封锁意味着美国海军可以扣押违反封锁的私有船只，事实上，此类船只及其货物可以被作为战利品索取。到了18世纪，存在一套被称为
prize law. And prize law worked like this. The Navy would board a ship to determine whether it was violating the blockade. And if the ship appeared to be in violation of the blockade, the captured ship would be sent to a union court where a prize court was located. The prize court would then determine whether the ship would be claimed as a prize of war. Now, prize law has some really wonderful terms, the prize master sailed the ship to the prize court and would provide all of the papers found on board the captured ship. And the lawyers involved would libel the prize. That means asking for an investigation of all of the facts to determine whether the ship and its cargo would be forfeited. After all the evidence was considered, the prize court would then condemn or
战利品法的复杂法律体系。战利品法的运作方式如下：海军会登上一艘船，以确定它是否违反了封锁。如果该船被认为违反了封锁，被捕获的船只将被送往设有战利品法院的联邦法院。然后，战利品法院将确定该船是否可以被当作战利品认领。战利品法有一些非常奇妙的术语，例如“战利品船长”将船只驶向战利品法院，并提供在被捕获船只上找到的所有文件。相关的律师会对战利品提起诉讼（libel the prize）。这意味着要求对所有事实进行调查，以确定该船及其货物是否将被没收。在考虑了所有证据之后，战利品法院将宣告没收或
release the prize. Now, at this point, you might be wondering, what does prize law have to do with the Civil War being a war. A lot, it turns out. And that is because Lincoln chose to impose a naval blockade rather than just close the ports of the South. Now, that choice is significant because a naval blockade under recognized principles of international law is allowed only in wartime between two enemy nations. Okay. Well, that was a problem for Lincoln, right? Because Lincoln's position was that the Confederacy was engaged in insurrection, not a war. If the Confederacy was engaged in a war with the United States, well, then other nations might recognize the South as a sovereign nation. But if this was not a true war, then the blockade was
释放战利品。此时，你可能会好奇：战利品法与南北战争是否是一场战争有什么关系？事实证明，关系重大。这是因为林肯选择实施海上封锁，而不是仅仅关闭南方的港口。这一选择意义重大，因为根据公认的国际法原则，海上封锁只允许在两个敌对国家之间的战时进行。好吧，这对林肯来说是个问题，对吧？因为林肯的立场是，南方邦联参与的是一场暴动，而不是战争。如果南方邦联与美国处于战争状态，那么其他国家可能会承认南方为一个主权国家。但如果这不是一场真正的战争，那么封锁就是
illegal. You see the problem. Yeah, it's tricky. Right. So if all of the ships seized during the blockade were unlawfully taken, then the union might be forced to pay huge sums in compensation. But Most importantly, if Lincoln did not have the authority to issue a blockade, then he lacked the authority to call up troops, to direct the Treasury to pay for the union effort, and even to issue the Emancipation Proclamation of 1863. All of these were acts issued under Lincoln's constitutional war authority. So if the blockade was unconstitutional, then these other things were too. The Amy Warwick, the Hiawatha, the Briante, and the Crenshaw had all been seized separately for violating the blockade. The owners and the merchants laying claim to these ships appealed to the Supreme Court,
非法的。你看出问题所在了吧。是的，这很棘手。没错。所以，如果在封锁期间被扣押的所有船只都是被非法扣押的，那么联邦可能被迫支付巨额赔偿金。但最重要的是，如果林肯没有权力发布封锁令，那么他就缺乏权力去征召军队、指示财政部为联邦的努力支付资金，甚至缺乏权力发布1863年的《解放黑奴宣言》。所有这些都是根据林肯的宪法战争权力发布的行为。因此，如果封锁是违宪的，那么其他这些事情也同样是违宪的。“艾米·沃里克号”、“海华沙号”、“布里安特号”和“克伦肖号”都是因违反封锁而被分别扣押的。这些船只的所有者和主张权利的商人向最高法院提起上诉，
and their legal claims were heard together in what would be known as the prize cases. In March of 1863, the Supreme Court decided by just one vote in favor of the Lincoln administration. Yes, according to the Supreme Court, this week. was a war, the concept wasn't limited just to a conflict between two independent nations. And yes, Lincoln did have constitutional authority to issue the blockade. And if war was brought to the United States by invasion or rebellion, as the court explained, the president was not just authorized, but required by the Constitution to resist what it called force by force. In other words, Lincoln did have the authority for the blockade, even though
他们的法律诉讼被合并审理，这就是著名的“战利品案”。1863年3月，最高法院仅以一票之差做出有利于林肯政府的判决。是的，根据最高法院当时的裁决，这是一场战争，这一概念并不局限于两个独立国家之间的冲突。是的，林肯确实拥有发布封锁令的宪法权力。正如法院所解释的那样，如果战争是通过入侵或叛乱强加给美国的，那么宪法不仅授权总统，而且要求总统以武力抗击所谓的武力。换句话说，林肯确实拥有实施封锁的权力，尽管
Congress hadn't approved it. The prize cases were a turning point in the constitutionality of the Civil War. And the prize cases also happen to be the only time the Supreme Court has ever addressed the constitutionality of presidential war power without congressional approval. Yet president after president has claimed that they have independent war authority, no matter what Congress might say. And that raises the question of whether President Trump can constitutionally order military strikes and would appear to be fishing boats in the Caribbean because the Trump administration alleges that these boats are carrying illegal drugs into the United States. So what do we know about these strikes in the Caribbean?
国会并未批准。战利品案是南北战争合宪性的一個转折点。而且战利品案也是最高法院唯一一次在没有国会批准的情况下审议总统战争权力的合宪性。然而，历任总统却一直声称他们拥有独立的战争权力，无论国会怎么说。这就引发了一个问题：特朗普总统是否能合宪地对加勒比海看似渔船的目标下令进行军事打击，因为特朗普政府指控这些船只正在向美国走私非法药物。那么我们对加勒比海的这些打击了解多少呢？
So remember that in March, President Trump signed a proclamation that designated Trendiagra or TDA as a designated foreign terrorist or organization. And TDA, as a reminder, is a criminal gang that originated in Venezuela, but now it's considered kind of a multinational criminal organization. And Trump's proclamation back then stated that TDA was perpetrating, attempting, and threatening an invasion or predatory incursion
请记住，在3月份，特朗普总统签署了一项公告，将“特伦德亚格拉”（简称 TDA）指定为外国恐怖组织。提醒一下，TDA 是一个起源于委内瑞拉的犯罪帮派，但现在它被认为是一种跨国犯罪组织。特朗普当时发布的公告称，TDA 正在实施、企图实施并威胁要对美国领土进行入侵或掠夺性袭击。
against the territory of the United States. And so in our previous episode, we talked about how this proclamation has been used by the Trump administration to detain Venezuelan non-citizens in the United States and then designate them as alien enemies and simply deport them.
所以在我们上一集中，我们讨论了特朗普政府如何利用这一公告来拘留美国的委内瑞拉非公民，然后将他们指定为敌国国民并直接将其驱逐出境。
And so there's been a controversy over that, of course. And that designation also leads us to these boat strikes. Right. On September 2nd, the Trump administration announced that it had carried out a strike on a drug-carrying boat that came from Venezuela and was operated by the TDA. Now, boat strike is really an indirect way of saying that the military had blown up the boat. Yeah. And the people on board, 11 of them, were killed.
因此，这当然引发了争议。这种定性也引出了我们刚刚提到的这些船只打击行动。没错。9月2日，特朗普政府宣布，他们对一艘来自委内瑞拉、由 TDA 运营的载毒船只实施了打击。船只打击其实是一个委婉的说法，意思是军方炸毁了这艘船。是的。船上的11人全部丧生。
And that was just the first boat strike. So as of today, we know of at least 21 U.S. military strikes on boats in the Caribbean that have killed at least 83 people. Wow. There are two known survivors that were sent back to their home countries of Ecuador and Colombia. And these strikes have taken place in international waters. And from the reporting, these strikes appeared mainly to be carried out by drones that are launched from U.S. naval ships. So are these strikes legal at all? simple answer is no yeah so i would think not assassinating people like this it seems pretty much like
而这仅仅是第一次船只打击行动。截至今天，我们所知的美国军方针对加勒比海船只的打击至少已有21次，造成至少83人死亡。哇。有两名已知的幸存者被送回了他们的祖国厄瓜多尔和哥伦比亚。这些打击发生在国际水域。根据报道，这些打击似乎主要是由从美国海军舰艇上发射的无人机执行的。那么这些打击到底合法吗？简单的回答是：不合法。是的，所以我想也是。像这样暗杀平民，看起来非常像是
summary execution yeah they are not justifiable under any rational reading of any law and even some of the most conservative legal analysts agree with that conclusion but why these strikes are unlawful takes a little bit of explanation and as we go through this topic i think you'll see why the boat strikes are both shocking, but also not entirely surprising at the same time. Let's start with the war power. The Constitution splits the war power between the Congress and the President, and we know that from the text itself. Article 2 designates the President as the commander-in-chief of our military,
即决处刑。是的，根据对任何法律的理性解读，它们都是站不住脚的，甚至一些最保守的法律分析人士也同意这一结论。但为什么这些打击是非法的，这需要一点解释。随着我们探讨这个话题，我想你会明白为什么这些船只打击既令人震惊，但同时又并非完全出乎意料。让我们从战争权力开始。宪法将战争权力在国会和总统之间进行分配，我们从文本本身就能看出这一点。宪法第二条将总统指定为我们军队的三军统帅，
and Article 1 gives Congress the power to declare war, to raise and support an army, and to provide and maintain a Navy. The only problem is that Congress hasn't declared a formal war since World War II, And yet we have sent troops to armed conflicts many, many, many times since World War II. So in many of these instances, Congress has formally given the president the ability to use military force by passing a law. And we can call that an authorization to use military force. And the Supreme Court has generally treated this as an acceptable constitutional compromise. It's not quite a war, but Congress is allowing the president to do this.
而第一条赋予国会宣战、筹建和支持军队以及提供和维持海军的权力。唯一的问题是，自二战以来，国会再也没有正式宣战过，然而自二战以来，我们已经多次向武装冲突派遣军队。因此，在许多此类情况下，国会通过立法正式赋予了总统使用军事力量的能力。我们可以称之为“使用军事力量授权”（AUMF）。最高法院通常将此视为一种可接受的宪法妥协。这算不上正式宣战，但国会允许总统这么做。
So Congress grants the president formal approval to send troops, and then the president is essentially acting under that congressional authority. So, for instance, after September 11th, 2001, when the terrorist attacks happened, Congress passed the 2001 authorization for the use of military force, or the 2001 AUMF. And the 2001 AUMF allows the president of the United States to use all necessary and appropriate force against. all nations or groups that planned, committed, or aided the 9-11 attacks. It's still in effect, actually. Wow. Yep. It's also true that every president has said that no matter what Congress says, the president
因此，国会授予总统派遣军队的正式批准，然后总统基本上是在该国会授权下行事的。例如，在2001年9月11日恐怖袭击发生后，国会通过了2001年《使用军事力量授权法》（简称 2001 AUMF）。2001 AUMF 允许美国总统对所有策划、实施或协助9·11袭击的国家或组织使用一切必要和适当的武力。实际上它现在仍然有效。哇。是的。同样真实的是，每一位总统都曾表示，无论国会怎么说，根据宪法第二条，美国总统都拥有自己固有的或隐含的战争权力。是什么让总统们认为他们拥有这种固有的战争权力呢？当我阅读宪法时，我可没读出这个。嗯，这只是一种主张，对吧？所以存在这个问题。
of the United States has his own inherent or implied warpower under Article 2 of the Constitution. What makes the president think that they have this inherent warpower? That's not what I read when I read it. Well, it's just an assertion, right? So there's that problem. but we can also return to the prize cases. There, the Supreme Court endorses the idea
但我们也可以回到战利品案。在那个案件中，最高法院背书了这样一种观点：即总统拥有保卫国家免受武装袭击、武装入侵的宪法权力，即使国会没有提供正式授权。所以我认为三个分支之间绝对存在一种共识，即总统拥有某种固有的战争权力。问题在于，目前还不清楚这种固有战争权力的局限性在哪里。
that the president has the constitutional authority to defend the country from an armed attack, an armed invasion, even if Congress doesn't provide formal authorization. So I think there's definitely agreement among all three branches that the president has some kind of inherent warpower. The problem is that it's not clear
按理说应该存在某种限制，否则就会颠覆我们对联邦政府有限权力理念的理解。因此必须存在某种限制，但它从未被明确定义。那么，到底是谁来定义什么是战争呢？嗯，这个问题没有确定的答案。国会和行政部门都宣称自己在谁来做最后决定这件事上拥有首要权。因此，最高法院的一些判决中对战争权力的范围给出了一些暗示。
what the limitations of this inherent war power is. Presumably there's some limit, Otherwise, that would upend our understanding of the federal government's idea of limited authority. So there has to be some limit, but it really hasn't been defined. So then who gets to define what a war is? Well, there's no definitive answer to that question. Both Congress and the executive branch have asserted their own primacy over who gets to make the final call. So there are some hints about the extent of war authority and some Supreme Court decisions.
但总的来说，美国最高法院就是不想卷入这种本质上属于政治决定的裁决中。究竟谁来决定战争何时算战争？因此，国会和总统之间总是进行着拉锯战。让我举个例子……我喜欢他们可以随心所欲地做决定这一点。就像：“哦，我们就是不想卷入其中。”这看起来太混乱了，你知道的。他们就是这么做的，是的。
But in general, the United States Supreme Court just doesn't want to get involved in making this essentially political determination. Who gets to make the final call in deciding when a war is a war? And so there's always a back and forth between the Congress and the president. So let me give you an... I love that they get to just decide. Like, we just don't want to get involved in this. It seems too messy, you know. And that's what they do, yeah.
完全正确。而且这并不是说——他们当然会卷入其他高度敏感的决定中。但关于发动战争，他们通常不会介入。好吧，有道理，行。那我来举个例子。2013年，在有报道称阿萨德政权对本国平民使用化学武器后，奥巴马政府考虑对叙利亚内战进行军事干预。因此，奥巴马在2013年上了电视，并宣布他实际上将询问国会是否会授权对叙利亚采取军事行动。
Exactly. And it's not, I mean, they'd certainly get involved in other highly charged decisions. Warmaking, they generally don't. Yeah, fair enough, okay. So let me give you an example. In 2013, the Obama administration considered military intervention in the Syrian civil war after reports that chemical weapons had been used by the Assad regime against its own civilians. So Obama went on TV in 2013, and he announced that he would actually ask Congress if they would authorize military action in Syria.
关于奥巴马的演讲，有趣的地方在于：与此同时，他在对公众说“我将向国会寻求授权”，他还说了这样一句话：“我相信我有权在没有国会具体授权的情况下采取这项军事行动。”所以你看，奥巴马两头占便宜。他说：“我不需要国会的许可，但我会表现得合作，无论如何我都会这么做。”这基本上是每一位现代美国总统的立场。我不需要向国会请求许可，但是呢，当它很方便的时候，我会向国会请求许可，尽管我其实并不需要。好吧。
Now, what's interesting about Obama's speech is, At the same time, he's telling the public, I'm going to ask Congress for authorization. He also said this, I believe I have the authority to carry out this military action without specific congressional authorization. So, you see, Obama's sort of having it both ways. He's saying, I don't need Congress's permission, but I'm going to be cooperative and I'm going to do it anyway. And that's been essentially the position of every single modern American president. I don't have to ask Congress for permission, but, you know, when it's convenient, I will ask Congress for permission, although I don't have to. Okay.
这就是《战争权力决议案》登场的地方。《战争权力法》的正式名称是《战争权力决议案》，但它实际上是一项在1973年推翻尼克松总统否决后通过的正式法律。好吧，那么《战争权力决议案》是做什么的呢？该决议实际上并没有赋予总统任何权力。相反，你可以将《战争权力决议案》视为国会介入并要求总统进行某种协调的一种方式。每当总统想要使用军事力量而又没有事先征得国会同意时，就会用到它。因此，该决议有几个条款，但以下是几个要点：《战争权力决议案》第四条要求总统在以下情况发生后的48小时内通知国会：每当美国武装部队被派遣进入——这里是具体的措辞，这对于后文很重要——敌对行动，或者进入局势表明明显存在迫在眉睫的敌对行动的环境中。
And so that's where the War Powers Resolution comes in. The formal name of the War Powers Act is the War Powers Resolution, but it's actually a formal law that was passed over Nixon's veto in 1973. Okay, so what does the War Powers Resolution do? So the resolution doesn't actually give the president any powers at all. Instead, you can think of the war powers resolution as a kind of a way for Congress to step in and ask for some coordination from the president. Anytime the president wants to use military force and the president doesn't ask Congress beforehand. So the resolution has several provisions, but here are the key points. Section four of the war powers resolution requires the president to tell Congress within 40, 48 hours, anytime that American armed forces are sent into, and here's the specific language, which will be important for later, hostilities or into situations where imminent hostility is clearly indicated by the circumstances.
对国会的这一通知应当解释总统用以使用军事力量的法律依据。所以这是一份正式的通知，告诉国会我在做什么以及我为什么要动用军队。总统还应当估计军事介入将持续多久、规模会有多大。当然，当这些事情发生时，在这个信息发达的世界里国会当然会知道，但这是一份正式通知。明白了，明白了。好的。《战争权力决议案》中对这里很重要的第二部分是：在采取该军事行动后的60天内，总统应当停止使用军队，除非国会宣战——这不会发生——或者给予总统其他某种正式授权，
That notification to Congress is supposed to explain the legal authority the president is relying on to use military force. So this is a formal, I'm telling Congress what I'm doing and why I'm using the military. And the president is also supposed to estimate how long and extensive the military involvement will be. So, of course, when these things happen, of course Congress knows in this world of media, but it's a formal notification. Got it, got it. Okay. So the second part of the war powers resolution that's important here is that within 60 days after that military action, the president is supposed to stop using the military, unless Congress declares war, it's not going to happen, or gives the president some other formal authorization.
或者由于美国正持续遭受某种攻击而出现某种国家紧急状态。当然，这也没有发生。现在，如果总统宣布存在某种不可避免的军事必要性，他可以将此期限再延长30天。因此，《战争权力决议案》有三个重要的数字：48小时、60天、90天。这一切都是为了确保当总统决定“嘿，我要因为某种原因把军队派往海外”时，国会和总统能够协同合作。
or there's some kind of national emergency because there's some ongoing attack on the United States. Of course, that doesn't happen either. Now, the president can extend this by another 30 days if he declares that there's some unavoidable military necessity. So the War Powers Resolution has three important numbers, 48 hours, 60 days, 90 days. And this is all meant to ensure that Congress and the president
是的，是的，是的。因此，自尼克松以来的每一位总统——当然尼克松曾试图否决该决议但没有成功——都对《战争权力决议案》是否真的合宪提出了质疑。但自尼克松以来的每一位总统，也都不同程度地遵守了该决议。就船只打击而言，特朗普是否在某种程度上遵循了《战争权力决议案》，还是完全置之不理？这到底是怎么回事？嗯，可以说是，也可以说不是。
work together whenever the president decides, hey, I'm going to send troops abroad for some reason. Yeah, yeah, yeah. So every president since Nixon, and of course Nixon tried to veto the resolution that didn't work, has raised doubts that the war powers resolution is actually constitutional. But every single president since Nixon has also complied with the resolution in varying degrees. In terms of the boat strikes, is Trump like engaging with the war powers resolution at all or are just ignoring it completely? What's going on? Well, yes and no.
让我们先来看看“是”的部分。所以在9月份第一次船只打击之后，特朗普确实在9月4日之后的48小时内向国会发送了一封正式信函。这封致国会的信函确认，美国军方确实在任何国家领海之外的地点打击了一艘船只。
So let's get to the yes. So after the first boat strike in September, Trump actually sent a formal letter to Congress within 48 hours on September 4th. And the letter to Congress confirms that the U.S. military did, in fact, strike a vessel at a location beyond the territorial seas of any nation.
现在，这封信还称，经评估，该船与某个被指定的恐怖组织有关联，并参与了非法贩毒活动。信中没有提到 TDA，但特朗普在船只打击时宣布，这是一针对 TDA 的行动。他在“真实社交”（Truth Social）上宣布了这一点。
Now, the letter also says that the boat was assessed to be affiliated with a designated terrorist organization and to be engaged in illicit drug trafficking activities. Now, it doesn't say anything about TDA, but Trump announced at the time of the boat strike that this was an action against TDA. He announced this on truth social.
这会持续多久？信中说：“嗯，我们不知道。目前无法得知这些军事行动的全部范围和持续时间。”因此，特朗普致国会的信说：“我写信给国会是为了遵守《战争权力决议案》”，但信中也表示，特朗普下令进行这些打击，
How long will this last? The letter says, well, we don't know. It's not possible to know at this time the full scope and duration of these military operations. So Trump's letter to Congress says, I'm writing to Congress because this is to comply with the war powers resolution, but the letter also says that Trump directed these strikes
是根据其作为三军统帅和行政长官、负责指挥美国外交关系的宪法权力行事的。所以，再次两头兼顾。我在遵守规定，但我其实不需要在这里寻求任何形式的批准，对吧？这与所有其他现代他们在遵守《战争权力决议案》时发布的48小时通知中所说的话非常相似。让我们退一步思考这意味着什么。特朗普说，我对这些船只使用了军事力量，其中至少有一些实际上
under his constitutional authority as commander-in-chief and chief executive to conduct United States foreign relations. So again, having it both ways. I'm complying, but I actually don't have to seek any kind of approval here, right? Very similar to what all other modern presidents have said in their own 48-hour notices any time that they've complied with the war powers resolution. So let's step back for a moment and think about what this means. Trump is saying, I've used military force against these boats, at least some of which actually
看起来像是渔船。但这种使用军事力量到底算什么？那么，他是在断言这实际上是一场战争吗？还是他根本没有在那种层面上进行论证？嗯，你知道的，如果你看一下致国会的信，特朗普政府声称它是在根据国家享有的自卫权行事。但如果在某种意义上这是一场战争，让我们暂时接受这个想法：船上的人怎么就成了与美国发生武装冲突的战斗人员了呢？对吧？即使我们假设这些船上确实有人在向美国走私非法药物（请记住，政府迄今为止还没有提供任何支持这一说法的证据），那么处理贩毒分子的通常方式也应当作为执法问题，
appear to be fishing boats. But what is this use of military force? So is he asserting that this is actually a war? Or is he even engaging with that level of argument at all? Well, you know, if you look at the letter to Congress, the Trump administration says that it is acting under the nation's right to self-defense. But if this is in some sense of war, let's go with that idea for a moment. How are the people in these boats combatants in armed conflict with the United States, right? Even if we assume that there are people in these boats who are bringing illegal drugs into the United States, and remember, the administration hasn't offered any evidence supporting this yet. Then the usual manner of dealing with drug runners would be as a matter of law enforcement,
而不是战争行为。对吧？当然。是的。所以你想必会有类似海岸警卫队这样的力量，去拦截船只、逮捕船员并将他们带回进行刑事起诉。但这些并不是司法起诉。他们只是炸毁了船只。这些是在没有任何程序的情况下进行的处刑。因此，如果你将非法毒品运入美国，这当然是一项犯罪，
not war making. Right? Of course. Yeah. So presumably you'd have something like the Coast Guard who would stop the boats and arrest the crew and bring them in for criminal prosecution. But these weren't prosecutions. They simply blew up the boats. These were executions without any process at all. And so if you bring illegal drugs in the United States, that's certainly a crime. but, you know, is it really an attack on the United States? That's not really the way we think about armed conflict. Yeah. And there's no sense that the TDA is engaged in any sustained or organized campaign against the United States as a sovereign nation, right?
但是，这真的是对美国的攻击吗？这并不是我们看待武装冲突的方式。是的。而且也没有迹象表明 TDA 正在对作为主权国家的美国展开任何持续或有组织的运动，对吧？武装冲突的一个基本原则意味着你必须区分战斗人员和平民。因此，即使我们假设这些人是贩毒分子，他们确实在向美国运送非法毒品，他们仍然是平民。他们没有穿制服。他们在任何意义上都没有试图假装成士兵。但政府在9月份告诉国会，本质上我们正在与非国家行为者进行武装冲突。他们把自己在这些船只上杀害的人称为战斗人员。所以这确实有些牵强。
And a basic principle of armed conflict means that you distinguish between combatants and civilians. So even if we assume that these are drug runners, that they are, in fact, bringing illegal drugs into the United States, they're still civilians. They're not wearing uniforms. They're not trying to pretend to be soldiers in any sense. But the administration told Congress in September that essentially we are in an armed conflict with non-state actors. And they call the people that they had killed in these boats combatants. So that's really a stretch.
但你看，他们试图断言这是美国卷入的某种战争。我明白了。但他们并不是。他们是平民。美国不能仅仅因为平民涉嫌向美国输入非法毒品就将他们杀死，对吧？这是第一个问题，也许也是最容易想到的一个问题。这根本不是一场战争，句号。所以特朗普动用了军队来做这件事。到目前为止，你知道的，已经是9月4日之后的两个月了。
But you see they're trying to assert that this is some kind of war that the United States is engaged in. I see. But they aren't. They're civilians. And the United States can't simply. kill civilians because they're allegedly importing illegal drugs into the United States, right? That's problem number one and maybe the easiest one to think about. Just isn't a war at all, period. So Trump used the military to do this. At this point, you know, it's two months after September 4th.
但你可以看到，他们正试图断言这是美国卷入的某种战争。我明白。但他们并非如此。他们是平民。美国不能仅仅因为这些平民涉嫌向美国输入非法毒品就将其杀害，对吧？这是第一个问题，或许也是最容易想到的一个。这根本不是一场战争，句号。所以特朗普动用了军方来做这件事。此时，你知道，距离9月4日已经过去两个月了。
So that 60 day where they have to stop using force unless Congress says so, we've reached past that point. What has happened in regards to that? Well, this is the trickier part. Remember the three numbers of the War Powers Resolution, you just brought up one, 48 hours, 60 days, 90 days. So it's very clear contemplation in the resolution that the President can't just go it alone if he orders the use of military force. He needs the cooperation and approval of Congress, right? When the military first blew up the boat on the first boat on September 2nd, that triggered not just the reporting requirement, but the 60-day clock that you just mentioned, right? So remember, the President is supposed to withdraw. the military force unless Congress authorizes the military action. But remember, the Trump
所以，必须停止使用武力（除非国会另有决定）的那60天期限，我们已经超过去了。关于这一点，到底发生了什么？嗯，这是比较棘手的部分。还记得《战争权力决议》中的三个数字吗？你刚才提到了一个：48小时、60天、90天。所以决议中非常明确地考虑到了，如果总统下令使用军事力量，他不能独断专行。他需要国会的合作和批准，对吧？当军方在9月2日第一次炸毁那艘船时，这不仅触发了报告要求，还触发了你刚才提到的60天倒计时，对吧？所以记住，按理说总统应该撤回军事力量，除非国会授权军事行动。但记住，特朗普
administration has continued to strike these boats and kill people, right? Dozens of people at this point. So the Trump administration, what are they doing? Did Congress approve? No. But they're declared it a national emergency? Not quite that. That would be like an alien invasion. But except that Trump is claiming that the war powers resolution doesn't constrain him at all. all, right? So the war powers resolution does recognize that the present has some inherent or implied constitutional authority to use military force. And the war powers resolution essentially says fine, but Congress does get to play a role here by authorizing that force at some point. Now, here's where the OLC is relevant. What is the OLC? Right. The Office of Legal Counsel.
政府一直在继续袭击这些船只并杀害平民，对吧？到目前为止已有数十人遇害。那么特朗普政府到底在干什么？国会批准了吗？没有。但他们宣布进入国家紧急状态了吗？倒也不完全是。那更像是外星人入侵。只不过特朗普声称《战争权力决议》根本无法约束他，对吧？所以《战争权力决议》确实承认，总统在动用武力方面拥有某些固有的或默示的宪法权力。而《战争权力决议》基本上是在说，好吧，但国会确实可以通过在某个时刻授权这种武力来发挥作用。现在，法律顾问办公室（OLC）在这个时候就派上用场了。什么是OLC？没错，就是法律顾问办公室。
Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah. The Office of Legal Counsel is a part of of the Justice Department that provides legal advice to the president. Now, let's go back to 2011. In 2011, the Obama administration's OLC looked at the history of presidential action and concluded that the president has constitutional authority that doesn't need any approval whenever military action would serve what it called important national interests. Important. Yeah, very important.
哦，对，对，对，对。法律顾问办公室是司法部的一部分，负责向总统提供法律意见。现在，让我们回到2011年。在2011年，奥巴马政府的法律顾问办公室研究了总统行动的历史，并得出结论认为：每当军事行动服务于所谓的“重要国家利益”时，总统就拥有不需要任何批准的宪法权力。重要。是的，非常重要。
That's not enough. That's a strong enough word. Okay, continue on. I'm sorry. And when the military action doesn't rise to war in the constitutional sense. So the OLC wrote the memo to justify whether Obama would have constitutional authority to use air strikes in Libya. So remember in 2010 and 2011, they were pro-democracy movements spreading across the Arab world in places like Egypt and Tunisia and Libya. In Libya, this led to a violent crackdown against civilians. And as a result, the UN Security Council had passed a resolution for military intervention in Libya.
这还不够。这个词的份量还不够重。好吧，你继续。对不起。并且，当军事行动在宪法意义上并未上升到战争的程度时。因此，法律顾问办公室撰写了这份备忘录，来论证奥巴马是否有宪法权力在利比亚使用空袭。所以请记住，在2010年和2011年，争取民主的运动正在整个阿拉伯世界蔓延，比如埃及、突尼斯和利比亚。在利比亚，这引发了针对平民的暴力镇压。因此，联合国安理会通过了一项关于对利比亚进行军事干预的决议。
And the United States was to lead the NATO coalition establishing a no-fly zone over the country. This was to protect civilians who were being targeted by the Qaddafi regime. That's a very specific objective, right? But the OLC is saying, well, we can do this because it serves important national interests. interests. That's a pretty broad standard supporting presidential authority. Real. Oh, my God. It's like, I want to murder these people. No, that's illegal. But it's important. Well, if it's important, I mean, then I guess so. Right, right. Crazy. Okay. Keep going.
美国将领导北约联盟在利比亚领空建立禁飞区。这是为了保护遭到卡扎菲政权针对的平民。这是一个非常具体的目标，对吧？但法律顾问办公室却说，嗯，我们可以这样做，因为它服务于重要的国家利益。这是一个支持总统权力的相当宽泛的标准。真的。天哪。这就像是，我想谋杀这些人。不，那是违法的。但这很重要。好吧，既然重要，那我觉得……好吧，好吧。太疯狂了。好吧。继续。
So, so there you have a pretty specific objective. And then the OLC says that's why we can do it. It's serving important national interests and it's really not war in the constitutional sense. Okay. Okay. That's 2011. But then you see this very same two-part test from the OLC being used by the Trump administration, the first Trump administration, to justify air strikes in Syria. And then we get to the boat strikes. According to reporting from the New York Times, the Justice Department has written a document justifying the boat strikes as lawful because Trump has inherent constitutional authority to order these strikes. Number one, because these boat strikes are in the
所以，你看，那里有一个非常具体的目标。然后法律顾问办公室说这就是我们可以这样做的原因。它服务于重要的国家利益，而且在宪法意义上确实不是战争。好吧。好吧。那是2011年。但随后你就会发现，法律顾问办公室的这套同样的“两步检验法”也被特朗普政府（第一届特朗普政府）用来为叙利亚的空袭辩护。然后我们就迎来了对船只的空袭。根据《纽约时报》的报道，司法部撰写了一份文件，为袭击船只的合法性辩护，理由是特朗普拥有下令进行这些袭击的固有宪法权力。第一，因为这些针对船只的袭击符合
the national interest. And two, these strikes are not war in the constitutional sense. That's the same two-part test that we've just talked about. So that means in one sense, the American military blowing up fishing boats in the Caribbean is shocking and unprecedented. But the legal pathway the Justice Department is using isn't wholly new, even if we couldn't have predicted it would be used in this particular and very extreme way. Again, we're running into this thing where language fails us because it can't stop a bad actor interpreting these as broadly as possible to sort of just to do whatever they want. Exactly.
国家利益。第二，这些袭击在宪法意义上不是战争。这就是我们刚才讨论的同一套“两步检验法”。所以从某种意义上说，美国军方在加勒比海炸毁渔船是令人震惊且前所未有的。但司法部所使用的法律途径并非完全新颖，即使我们无法预测它会以这种特定且极端的方式被再次使用。我们又遇到了这种情况：语言让我们失望了，因为它无法阻止坏把戏的施行，无法阻止别有用心者将这些法律解释得尽可能宽泛，从而随心所欲地做任何他们想做的事。完全正确。
I mean, you know, we sort of think, well, with a good faith president, we think, well, that's a broad standard about maybe, you know, you could differ on whether that's appropriate in a policy sense, but we never would have thought we'd get to the boat strike situation. Totally. Unfortunately, it gets worse. There's another significant interpretation of the War Powers Resolution that's important here, too. So, Roman, remember that the War Powers Resolution applies whenever the President sends armed forces into hostilities or into situations where imminent hostility is clearly indicated by the circumstances. Yes.
我的意思是，你知道，我们往往会想，好吧，如果遇到一个诚信的总统，我们就会觉得，这是一个宽泛的标准，或许在政策意义上，你可能会对它是否合适有不同的看法，但我们绝不会想到我们会落入船只空袭这种境地。完全如此。不幸的是，情况更糟了。这里还有另一个对《战争权力决议》的重要解释，同样非常关键。所以，罗曼，请记住，《战争权力决议》适用于总统派遣武装部队进入敌对状态，或者进入由环境明显表明迫在眉睫的敌对状态的情况。是的。
So what's your general sense of what we mean when we say hostilities? that they are attacking the United States. That would be my sense of what hostilities are. Yeah. I mean, that's pretty reasonable. The problem is that the war powers resolution does not define what hostilities are, right? But the underlying presumption is that the war powers resolution only applies when there are hostilities. Then the president has to tell Congress and then later ask Congress for permission to keep using the military.
那么，对于当我们说“敌对状态”时到底是什么意思，你有什么总体看法？他们正在攻击美国。这就是我对敌对状态的理解。是的。我的意思是，这相当合理。问题在于，《战争权力决议》并没有定义什么是敌对状态，对吧？但潜在的假设是，《战争权力决议》仅在存在敌对状态时才适用。然后总统必须通知国会，随后要求国会允许继续使用军事
force. But because the act doesn't define the term, that's become contested too. So let's go back to 2011 and Libya again. So Obama did notify Congress in March of 2011 about the military campaign. And the airstrikes kept going, and they kept going on after the time allowed by the War Powers Resolution, and Congress had not authorized it. Well, in June of 2011, President Obama sent a report to Congress, and the gist of it was, well, the military is not engaged in hostilities. So the war powers resolution doesn't apply. So why not? What was the justification here?
力量。但由于该法案没有对该术语进行定义，这也成了争论的焦点。所以让我们再次回到2011年和利比亚。奥巴马确实在2011年3月就军事行动通知了国会。空袭一直在继续，并且在《战争权力决议》允许的时间到期后仍然在继续，而国会并未授权此事。好吧，在2011年6月，奥巴马总统向国会提交了一份报告，其核心意思是，嗯，军方并未参与敌对状态。因此《战争权力决议》不适用。那么为什么不适用呢？这里的理由是什么？
Well, according to the Obama administration, the use of American military force was not sustained fighting or active exchanges of fire with hostile forces, nor do they involve U.S. ground troops. So remember, this was part of a NATO coalition to enforce a no-fly zone from the air. There were no U.S. troops on the ground. And Obama administration lawyers argued, like, Libyan forces couldn't realistically fire back. So this wasn't a hostility. So, you know, these Venezuelan fishermen or Ecuadorian Caribbean fishermen are not firing back at the drones either. So does that apply here, too? Yeah, that's essentially what they're saying.
好吧，根据奥巴马政府的说法，美国军事力量的使用并不构成持续的战斗或与敌对力量的积极交火，也没有涉及美军地面部队。所以请记住，这是北约联军从空中强制执行禁飞区行动的一部分。地面上没有美军士兵。奥巴马政府的律师辩称，利比亚军队实际上无法还击。所以这不构成敌对状态。所以，你知道，这些委内瑞拉渔民或厄瓜多尔加勒比海渔民也没有向无人机开火還击。所以这同样适用于这里吗？是的，这基本上就是他们的说法。
In early November, the Justice Department told Congress that Trump was going to continue to order lethal strikes on boats that were suspected of bringing illegal drugs into the United States. And they said, what? Well, these don't count as hostilities under the war powers resolution. I guess the idea seems to be these aren't hostilities because the people in the boats can't shoot back. Yeah. Because they aren't armed possibly would be the reason. Yeah, or, you know, I mean, but it's so, this is so infuriating because the pretense of doing it at all is that these people are combatants that are shooting or shooting back. Right.
在11月初，司法部告知国会，特朗普将继续下令对涉嫌将非法毒品运入美国的船只进行致命打击。他们说，什么？好吧，根据《战争权力决议》，这些不计入敌对状态。我想他们的想法似乎是这些不算敌对状态，因为船上的人无法还击。是的。可能因为他们没有武装，所以才这么认为。是的，或者，你知道，我的意思是，但这太令人愤怒了，因为进行这种行动的借口本来是这些人是开枪或准备还击的战斗人员。没错。
And then when confronted with the fact that if people are shooting back, you need to behave this way, they're like, no, they weren't shooting back. It's so, that is so infuriating. In both cases, it's infuriating. Right. And remember, why is the Trump administration doing this? They're trying to avoid being restrained by that 60 days. clock. Yeah. That would require Trump to stop the boat strikes or to have Congress approve of what he is doing, which I think seems unlikely. Yeah. Yeah. So these boat strikes are definitely
而当面对“如果人们正在还击，你就需要按这种方式行事”这一事实时，他们的态度却是：不，他们没有还击。这太令人愤怒了。在两种情况下都令人愤怒。没错。而且请记住，特朗普政府为什么要这样做？他们正试图避免受到那60天倒计时的约束。是的。那将要求特朗普停止对船只的袭击，或者让国会批准他正在做的事情，而我认为这似乎不太可能。是的。是的。所以这些船只袭击绝对是
unprecedented. I mean, Trump is ordering the execution by the military of people who are allegedly, allegedly bringing drugs into the United States rather than apprehending them and arresting them. That is unprecedented. But Trump's attempts to legally justify what's happening, is that by itself is not completely a surprise. So if you go back to 2011, the Obama administration interpreted the Constitution and the war powers resolution so that the United States could participate in part of this NATO coalition effort. And we could raise questions about the wisdom of that specific intervention, but it was backed by a UN Security Council resolution. And the reason this happened, or the reason why the Obama administration took the direction
前所未有的。我的意思是，特朗普下令由军方处决那些据称（据称）将毒品运入美国的人，而不是抓捕和逮捕他们。这真是前所未有。但特朗普试图从法律上为正在发生的事情辩护，单凭这一点本身并不完全令人意外。所以如果你回溯到2011年，奥巴马政府对宪法和《战争权力决议》进行了解释，以便美国能够参与北约联军的这项努力。我们可以对那次特定干预的明智性提出质疑，但它得到了联合国安理会决议的支持。之所以发生这种情况，或者说奥巴马政府采取这一方向的原因
it did was because there were a lot of Republicans who objected to this particular intervention. It was not realistic that he was going to get congressional authorization, so it crafted a legal interpretation to try to justify its use of military force. But even if you disagreed with what the U.S. was doing, I don't think we'd really call it the actions of a rogue president. We might say, well, you know, maybe the U.S. shouldn't have intervened to the extent that it did or to the amount of time that it did. But it's not exactly a rogue president. in this way. But I don't want to just dump on Obama here. We can go back further to 2001. Now, the country's response to the terrorist attacks of 9-11 was to pass the 2001 AUMF. And again,
是因为有许多共和党人反对这次特定的干预。他要想获得国会授权是不切实际的，因此他精心设计了一种法律解释，试图为自己使用军事力量的行为辩护。但即使你不同意美国当时的行为，我想我们也不会真的称其为一个独裁者的行为。我们可能会说，嗯，也许美国不应该干预到那种程度，或者持续那么长时间。但它并不完全是以这种方式行事的独裁总统。但我不想在这里一味地贬低奥巴马。我们可以追溯到更早的2001年。当时，国家对9·11恐怖袭击的回应是颁布了2001年的《授权使用军事力量》（AUMF）。同样，
that AUMF has not expired. It is still in force today. In fact, the 2001 AUMF has been used to address terrorist organizations that didn't even exist in 2001. And so for that reason, the 2001 AUMF has been called the beginning of our forever wars, in part because it's just not clear how the objectives of the 2001 AUMF that stretches from the Bush administration to today, how those objectives will ever be completed? How will we know that those objectives are done? And even before 9-11, presidents have long argued that their constitutional authority to exercise the war power, is very, very broad, so broad that Congress can't really impose any checks on it.
那个《授权使用军事力量》并未失效。它至今仍然有效。事实上，2001年的《授权使用军事力量》甚至被用来对付那些在2001年根本不存在的恐怖组织。正因如此，2001年的《授权使用军事力量》被称为我们永无休止的战争的开端，部分原因在于人们根本不清楚，从布什政府一直延续到今天的2001年《授权使用军事力量》的目标将如何才能完成？我们怎么知道这些目标已经达成？甚至在9·11之前，总统们长期以来一直争辩说，他们行使战争权力的宪法权力是非常非常广泛的，广泛到国会根本无法对其施加任何制衡。
But, of course, it takes Trump, right, a president who's not fond of any limits at all to really force us to ask what kind of limitations there should be on what the president's war-making authority is. Yeah. Has there ever been an effort to pass another bill like rescinding the 2001 A-U-M-F? Oh, there are often many calls, there have been many calls to do this, but they've been unsuccessful. I mean, for lots of reasons, but I think maybe the obvious political reason is, you know, politically, you wouldn't want to do that as a lawmaker to say we should get rid of this. But as a result, we have this very old authorization that is very broad, allows the president to do all kinds of things.
但是，当然，只有特朗普——一个根本不喜欢任何限制的总统——才会真正迫使我们去思考，对于总统的战争制造权力，到底应该存在什么样的限制。是的。以前有没有人努力通过另一项法案来废除2001年的《授权使用军事力量》？哦，经常有这种呼吁，过去有过很多次这样做的呼吁，但都失败了。我的意思是，原因有很多，但我认为最明显的政治原因可能是，作为一名立法者，从政治上讲，你不会想这么做，不想去说我们应该废除这个东西。但其结果是，我们拥有了这项非常古老且极其宽泛的授权，它允许总统做各种各样的事情。
And presidents of both parties have relied on the AMF to engage in military actions all over the world that, you know, sometimes have kind of just a secondary association with what happened in 9-11. It still leads us back to this foundational part of the Constitution, which is that it wasn't built around parties. It was built around opposing branches and that the loyal opposition wasn't just the other party. The loyal opposition was the legislative branch because when you see this 1973 Act, you know, trying to rain in Nixon, it's like a veto-proof majority passed it. And it really takes Congress saying, no, though this is our domain and we're going to fight back with it. And if they, you know, try to work around it, fine. And they pass other laws. And they, you know, like, but it requires that sort of jockeying to come to, you know, some kind of solution that represents America in some way.
两党总统都曾依靠《授权使用军事力量》在世界各地参与军事行动，这些行动有时与9·11事件只有某种次要的关联。这依然让我们回到了宪法的这一基础部分，即它不是围绕政党建立的。它是围绕相互抗衡的政府分支建立的，忠诚的反对派不仅仅是另一个政党。忠诚的反对派是立法机构，因为当你看到这个1973年的法案（试图遏制尼克松）时，你会发现它是由一个足以推翻总统否决权的多数派通过的。这确实需要国会站出来说：不，这是我们的地盘，我们要用它来进行反击。如果他们（总统）试图绕过它，好吧。他们还会通过其他法律。他们，你知道，比如，但这就需要那种政治博弈来最终达成某种代表美国的解决方案。
And if you don't have that, then you have nothing. You just have a person who can just run roughshod over all morals and ethics. I think that's right. And also remember, because of the way the war powers are defined, meaning not defined, very clearly, and the Supreme Court doesn't get involved in these kinds of questions, it means that it's just an endless, ongoing, unresolved conversation between Congress and the president. And remember, presidents continue to raise the question. I don't even think that Congress has the authority to do this. Make me report. I will report if I feel like it.
如果你没有这个，那你什么都没有。你只有一个能够践踏所有道德和伦理的人。我认为这很对。而且还要记住，由于战争权力的定义方式（也就是没有明确定义），并且最高法院不介入这类问题，这意味着这只是国会与总统之间一场永无止境的、正在进行的、尚未解决的对话。记住，总统们一直在提出这个问题。我甚至不认为国会有权这样做。让我报告。如果我觉得高兴，我会报告。
But sometimes if I don't feel like it, I'm not going to comply at all. And Congress's hands are tied. And also, if you think about it, what is the president doing? Any president who orders military force is using our troops, which means paying for the troops, paying for everything they need. One thing that Congress could do, even without the compliance of the president, would be fine, we'll withdraw the funding. But Congress is never going to do that. Never going to do that. Yeah.
但有时如果我不高兴，我根本就不会遵守。国会的双手被绑住了。而且如果你仔细想想，总统在做什么？任何下令使用军事力量的总统都在调动我们的军队，这意味着要支付军队的费用，支付他们需要的一切费用。国会能做的一件事（甚至无需总统配合）就是，好吧，我们撤回资金。但国会永远不会那样做。永远不会那样做。是的。
I mean, sometimes it's okay to have things be undefined in words so that it forces negotiations. and that negotiation is, like, part of the ongoing conversation of what it is to make a society. Like, I'm okay with that. You know, like, you know, like having discretion and discussion and negotiation, you know, instead of, like, a wall, for example. You know what I mean? Like, you know, like having a not a hard solution, but a negotiation solution. So, like, as things develop, that's fine. But this one seems particularly messy.
我的意思是，有时候在文字上保持一些模糊性是件好事，这样可以迫使各方进行谈判，而这种谈判就是构建社会这一持续对话的一部分。我觉得这没问题。你知道，就像，你知道，拥有自由裁量权、讨论和谈判，而不是像筑起一堵墙那样，例如。你知道我的意思吗？就像，你知道，不是提供一个硬性的解决方案，而是一个通过谈判达成的解决方案。所以，随着事情的发展，这没问题。但这一个似乎特别混乱。
Like, because there's so many lives and so much awful activity can happen underneath the, sort of the vagaries of trying to work this stuff out. I think that's right. And also, you know, the problem is, you know, even if there is an emergency power that we want to keep in reserve for the president of the United States, the problem is when everything is an emergency, as the Trump administration keeps asserting, then this expansive power is never going to end. And we can't always point to the civil war as our precedent because that was the national
因为在试图解决这些事情的种种不确定性之下，会发生如此多的生命消逝和如此多可怕的活动。我认为这很对。而且，你知道，问题在于，你知道，即使存在一种我们希望为美国总统保留的紧急权力，问题是当一切都成了紧急情况（正如特朗普政府不断坚称的那样），这种膨胀的权力就永远不会结束。我们不能总是把内战作为我们的先例，因为那是国家
emergency. The nation almost split apart. But that's not the way we think of. ordinary uses of military force. Yeah. As soon as you read some part of the law that says emergency, I'm like, oh, well, this is the end. This is a huge problem for us because he's just, emergency here, emergency there, emergency,
紧急状态。国家差点分裂。但这并不是我们对军事力量常规使用的看法。是的。一旦你读到法律中提到“紧急情况”的某个部分，我就会想，哦，好吧，这下完了。这对我们来说是个巨大的问题，因为他只会说：这里紧急，那里紧急，紧急，
I ran out of milk, emergency. Like, everything is an emergency. And no one anticipated that. We maybe need a new stronger word than emergency. I don't know what it is, but we maybe need something else to put into our laws. That's right. Well, this was really fascinating stuff. Thank you so much for talking me through it.
我没有牛奶了，紧急。就像，每件事都是紧急情况。没有人预料到这一点。我们可能需要一个比“紧急情况”更强烈的词。我不知道那是什么词，但我们可能需要在法律中加入点别的什么。没错。嗯，这真的是非常迷人的内容。非常感谢你跟我探讨这些。
Thanks, Roman. Join us next month. We're continuing our discussion of Article 2. We covered a lot with Secretary Napolitano, but there's plenty more to talk about. The 99% Invisible Breakdown of the Constitution is produced by Isabel Angel, edited by committee, music by Swan Real and from Doomtree Records,
谢谢你，罗曼。欢迎下个月继续收听我们关于第二条的持续讨论。我们和纳波利塔诺部长探讨了很多内容，但还有很多事情可以聊。《99%隐形》对宪法的剖析由伊莎贝尔·安吉尔制作，委员会编辑，音乐由斯旺·里尔和杜姆树唱片公司提供，
mixed by Martine Gonzalez. 99% Invisible's executive producer is Kathy 2, Our senior editor is Delaney Hall. Kurt Colestead is the digital director. The rest of the team includes Chris Barubei, Jason DeLeon, Emmett Fitzgerald, Christopher Johnson, Vivian Lay, Lashemadon, Jacob Medina Gleason, Kelly, Kelly Prime, Joe Rosenberg, Talon and Rain Stradley, and me, Roman Mars. The 99% of visible logo was created by Stefan Lawrence. The art for this series was created by Aaron Nestor. We are part of the Sirius XM podcast family, now headquartered six blocks north in the Pandora building and beautiful.
由马丁·冈萨雷斯混音。《99%隐形》执行制作人是凯西·2，我们的高级编辑是德兰尼·霍尔。库尔特·科尔斯特德是数字总监。团队其他成员包括克里斯·巴鲁贝伊、杰森·德莱昂、埃met特·菲茨杰拉德、克里斯托弗·约翰逊、维维安·莱、拉谢马顿、雅各布·梅迪纳·格里森、凯利、凯利·普赖姆、乔·罗森伯格、塔隆和雷恩·斯特拉德利，以及我，罗曼·马尔斯。《99%隐形》的标志由斯特凡·劳伦斯创作。本系列的艺术作品由亚伦·内斯特创作。我们是Sirius XM播客家族的一员，现在总部设在潘多拉大楼以北六个街区的美丽地方。
You can find the show on all the usual social media sites as well as your own Discord server where we have fun discussions about constitutional law, about architecture, about movies, about music. We talk about the power broker like a lot, all kinds of good stuff. It's where I'm hanging out most of the time these days. You can find a link to the Discord server as well as every past episode of 99PI at 99PI.org. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
你可以在所有常见的社交媒体网站以及你自己的Discord服务器上找到这个节目，我们在那里就宪法、建筑、电影、音乐进行有趣的讨论。我们聊了很多关于权力掮客的话题，各种好东西。这些天我大部分时间都在那里闲逛。你可以在 99PI.org 上找到 Discord 服务器的链接以及 99PI 以往的每一集节目。这一集目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。